et donc aujourd'hui on va vous parler du
sujet préféré des français quand il
s'agit de débattre de l'énergie c'est à
dire du nucléaire comme vous le savez
quand on fait avec les atom
on peut entre guillemets obtenir ou
faire interagir un atom avec du renfort
avec de l'énergie de deux manières enfin
il ya deux manières distinctes de
comment il faut dire exactement où c'est
ça d'avoir de l'énergie impliqué dans
quelque chose qui se passe au niveau
d'un atome
vous pouvez soit avoir un réarrangement
des couches d'électronique et à ce
moment ça s'appelle soit une excitation
soit une réaction chimique ou vous
pouvez avoir un réarrangement des
nucléons et à ce moment ça s'appelle une
énergie nucléaire
donc c'est l'énergie nucléaire c'est
l'énergie du réarrangement des nucléons
que vous pouvez avoir avec des noyaux
atomiques
il ya deux manières d'obtenir ou plus
exactement d'avoir de l'énergie
nucléaire la première c'est l'énergie
qui est associé à la fission la fission
sait on prend un gros noyau en cassant
deux enfants ou plus exactement en deux
gros morceaux et en plein d'autres
petits et ça c'est une réaction qui
libèrent de l'énergie et la deuxième
manière si vous allez voir pourquoi
c'est au contraire de prendre des noyaux
très légers et défusionnées et à ce
moment c'est pareil vous avez de
l'énergie qui est disponible en gros
dans les deux cas de figure il faut
qu'on profite du fait que l'énergie de
liaison dans les atomes dans les noyaux
pardon n'est pas la même quelle que soit
la taille du noyau est donc dans les
petits et les très gros noyau l'énergie
de liaison elle est un peu plus faible
que dans les noyaux intermédiaires et
donc en réarrangeant la taille des
noyaux vous pouvez obtenir de l'énergie
donc en gros ou bien vous faites de la
fission la fission ça consiste à faire
cette réaction la casse et un noyau en
deux avec libération d'énergie
cette énergie comme on va le voir elle
est essentiellement contenu soit dans du
rayonnement électromagnétique soit dans
l'énergie cinétique des bouts de noyaux
donc des petits noyaux après scission
soit pardon on fait le
l'exact inverse c'est à dire on fait de
la fusion c'est à dire qu'on assemble on
fait du haut anjou au lego et à ce
moment le différentiel de d'énergie de
liaisons se retrouvent également
libérées dans l'environnement sous forme
également d'énergie cinétique et de
rayonnement électromagnétique quelque
chose qui est important c'est de savoir
qu' il y a un énorme facteur
multiplicateur entre l'énergie chimique
c'est à dire l'énergie du réarrangement
des électrons que vous pouvez avoir avec
un atom et l'énergie nucléaire c'est à
dire l'énergie du réarrangement des ducs
léon et l'ordre de grandeur entre les
deux qu'il faut garder en tête c'est de
l'ordre du million bondy autrement vous
avez un million de fois plus d'énergie
dans la fission d'un gramme d'uranium
que dans la combustion d'un gramme de
pétrole je vous le dis encore autrement
scissionner un gramme d'uranium libère
la même quantité d'énergie thermique que
de brûler une tonne de pétrole et la
raison à cela c'est que l'énergie
typique de réarrangement d'une couche
electronics et quelques électrons volt
l'énergie typique d'une réaction de
fission ces quelques centaines de
millions d'électronvolts dont vous
perdez une partie au passage mais peu
importe donc là la raison pour laquelle
il ya l'énergie nucléaire est très
concentré c'est lié à ça c'est lié au
fait que l'énergie de réarrangement des
noyaux dans un atome est quelque chose
de beaucoup plus intense que l'énergie
de réarrangement des électrons on a soit
dit en passant une grosse bombe
thermonucléaire permanente dans notre
environnement qui nous rend bien service
et qui s'appelle le soleil donc le
soleil c'est un endroit où vous avez de
la fusion en permanence s'est passé
euros est ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
en fait toutes les énergies que nous
utilisons sur terre sont des dérivés
directe ou indirecte de l'énergie
nucléaire le rayonnement solaire à
l'évidence dérivés de l'énergie
nucléaire toutes les énergies fossiles
sont deux sont des énergies dérivé de la
photosynthèse donc indirectement dérivé
du rayonnement solaire donc de l'énergie
nucléaire
et c'est gros sans énergie nucléaire
nous ne sommes pas sur terre et toutes
les énergies que nous utilisons sont des
dérivés plus ou moins directe de
l'énergie nucléaire le vent c'est pareil
et c'est donc le un truc qui est
intéressant à avoir en tête c'est que
c'est amusant mais l'énergie nucléaire à
l'origine encore une fois d'à peu près
toutes les sources d'énergie qu'on
utilise sur terre le nucléaire a une
particularité qui n'en est pas une c'est
que comme vous le savez probablement il
a démarré son existence sur terre sous
forme militaire
la première alors en fait c'est pas tout
à fait vrai parce que la vente sur la
bombe atomique
il a fallu faire la pile de fermi qui
soit dit en passant dégagez l'énergie la
puissance totalement ridicule d'un délit
watts puis le fermi on peut faire des
tout petits réacteurs nucléaires la
preuve c'est que la pile de fermi
faisait un demi watts de puissance mais
après les premières manifestations
visibles ont été des manifestations aux
militaires et du coup c'est une partie
de la mauvaise presse qui est lié au
nucléaire cela étant quand vous regardez
un peu dans l'histoire des technologies
des hommes
enfin vos mises au point par les hommes
à peu près tout ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui à titre civil et
malheureusement n'est je ne peux pas
tous beaucoup de trucs sont nés à cause
de velléités militaire c'est notamment
le cas pour la robotique par exemple
c'est le cas pour internet
c'est le cas pour une bonne partie des
engins à moteur etc on a d'abord cherché
à en faire des usages militaires avant
d'en faire des usages civils donc de ce
point de vue le nucléaire fait pas
exception
je sais pas s'il faut dire heureusement
ou malheureusement alors quand on
s'intéresse à la production électrique
le nucléaire fondamentalement
fondamentalement c'est une manière de
faire bouillir de l'eau c'est
fondamentalement ça donc une centrale
nucléaire c'est fondamentalement une
bouilloire compliqué ces sacs c'est
aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose qui
permet de faire bouillir de l'eau en
grande quantité sans utiliser
d'oxydation du carbone c'est-à-dire sans
combustion et on va le voir
nonobstant ce qui peut être dit ici et
là pour pas très cher
on n'aura pas le temps aujourd'hui de
disserter de façon approfondie sur tous
ses aspects et même si j'avais eu leur
heure normale malheureusement j'aurais
pas eu le temps parce que c'est des
débats techniques et compliqué mais en
gros c'est ça l'idée c'est une grande
quantité de quantité d'énergie pas de
combustion et pas très très cher la
différence entre une centrale nucléaire
est une centrale à charbon ou une autre
centrale thermique elle est donc dans la
manière de produire la chaleur en ce qui
concerne une centrale à charbon ou fait
brûler du charbon en ce qui concerne une
centrale nucléaire vous faites
fissionner des atomes tout ce qui se
passe derrière est identique
c'est-à-dire que dans un cas comme dans
l'autre ça va vous dégager les grandes
quantités de chaleur avec ses grandes
quantités de chaleur vous allez créer de
la vapeur et avec cette vapeur vous
allez faire courber tourner une turbine
donc un truc avec des ailettes et il se
passe la même chose que dans
l'alternateur de votre voiture c'est à
dire qu'une fois que vous avez mis un
rotor en rotation dans un champ
magnétique et bien ça vous sort du
courant vous pouvez avoir dans les deux
cas de figure où pas ce qu'on appelle un
aéroréfrigérants sert cette grande tour
que vous voyez c'est l'image d'epinal de
la centrale nucléaire à la télévision
c'est cette grande tour qui fument alors
en fait cette grande tour qui fument
n'est rien d'autre qu'une tour de
refroidissement
c'est donc votre source froide de votre
machine de cardo et 7 tours de
refroidissement
pardon vous en avez besoin
que vous ayez du nucléaire ou que vous
ayez du charbon dès lors que vous êtes
en bord de rivière et donc que vous avez
besoin de la chaleur latente
d'évaporation pour refroidir parce que
le débit de la rivière n'est pas
suffisant pour refroidir simplement par
conduction thermique
quand vous êtes en bord de mer votre
source froide c'est d'aller prendre les
calories ou d'aller perdre des calories
plus exactement dans la mer et vous
n'avez pas besoin d'aero réfrigérant
donc quand vous regardez une centrale
nucléaire française qui est située en
bord de mer d'arabie nous penly où
blayais et bien vous n'avez pas d'aero
réfléchir par contre quand vous avez une
centrale à charbon en bord de rivière
vous avez une tour de refroidissement
comme celle là donc la tour de
refroidissement
ce n'est pas l'apanage du nucléaire
c'est l'apanage de la centrale thermique
en bord de rivière
le nucléaire et comme je l'avais c'est
une manière de produire de l'électricité
donc c'est quelque chose que vous voyez
apparaître dans les énergies finale ici
là dans l'électricité
c'est une c aujourd'hui j'ai dit la
dernière fois c'est un peu moins de 15 %
d'électricité mondiale c'est une part
qui a plutôt tendance à baisser un peu
parce que le nucléaire en gros est
plutôt une énergie aujourd'hui capable
ou la cote
par rapport à d'autres alors si je
regarde combien est ce que l'on fait on
produit d'énergie nucléaire dans le
monde
vous voyez ici la production depuis 1965
dans le monde
c'est une énergie qui est très récent
parcours une fois la pile de fermi ses
42 ans donc avant 42 il n'avait pas
beaucoup
vous voyez que c'est quelque chose qui
s'est fortement accélérée après les
chocs pétroliers qui a fortement ralenti
au moment dé contrechoc dans les années
80 qui s'est beaucoup calmé après le
début des années 2000 on va dire à un
moment où soit dit en passant pétrole
était pas très cher ici vous voyez la
conséquence à la fois de la crise de
2009 et de fukushima et puis deux puis
ça recommence à monter gentiment on
verra que les japonais redémarre des
réacteurs les uns derrière les autres
alors là vous avez une image un peu
globale en ce qui concerne le nucléaire
après vous pouvez avoir des images qui
sont extrêmement discriminés par par
pays alors ici vous avez l'exemple de
l'italie l'italie comme vous le voyez à
un réacteurs nucléaires en
fonctionnement alors pardon la puissance
typique d'un réacteur nucléaire c'est
entre un demi gigawatts et un gigawatt
le p r c'est un très gros réacteur qui
fait un gigawatt et demi mais c'est
entre la demie et un gigawatt
est ce que vous savez qu'on rie adore
dans l'année 1760
donc si vous prenez un gigawatt et que
ça fonctionne à puissance maximale toute
l'année à la fin de l'année vous avez
bien qu'elle production électrique 2007
160 gigawattheures
si on traduit 100 térawattheures ça fait
7 8 ans alors comme une centrale
nucléaire ça fonctionne pas tout le
temps parce que tu en entends faut
l'arrêter pour recharger pour et c'est
pour faire des matches des trucs et des
machins et puis de temps en temps ça
fonctionne pas à pleine puissance dans
certains pays pas en france mais en
france ça fonctionne pas tout à fait
puissance pardon dont la quasi-totalité
des autres pays six en gros retenez
qu'une centrale nucléaire de 1 gigawatt
dans l'année elle va vous produire de 6
à 8 heures à 8 heures
donc ça vous donne une règle une règle
simple une fois que vous voyez sur les
graphiques la quantité de tera watt a
reproduit dans l'année là vous voyez
qu'un à 4 d'abord et 8 ans suit donc ça
ça vous dit l'italie avait d'abord un
réacteurs d'un gigawatt ou deux d'un
demi gigawatts je sais pas puis ensuite
elle a doublé 100 c'est ça que ça veut
dire oui non une centrale prévoit
plusieurs réacteurs en france et 3 4 la
plus grosse et gravelines qui doit avoir
5 ou 6 je sais plus et vous pouvez
descendre à 2 mai mais en général vous
en avez plusieurs sur ce site donc là
vous voyez
l'italie à un réacteur en fonctionnement
énorme et un deuxième en fonctionnement
et puis là qu'est ce qui se passe
tchernobyl référendum en italie décision
de sortie du nucléaire et crac overnight
ya plus rien ici vous avez un autre pays
bien connu c'est le japon donc vous
voyez le japon a une production qui
augmente
qui est quasi stable avec de temps en
temps il va ya dû y avoir des fermetures
là vous avez fukushima et puis ils ont
commencé à redémarrer
il y en a démarré 8 laoudi chaussée
plusieurs favoris ici vous avez
d'allemagne alors l'allemagne
j'ai volontairement masquer les abscisse
il n'ya pas les abscisses et vous savez
que l'allemagne a décidé de sortir du
nucléaire
alors question est ce que vous pouvez me
dire à quoi correspond cette année là
alors une première seule une première
suggestion c'est tchernobyl deuxième
suggestion c'est fukushima
et bien la réponse est dit l'un des
autres
début du plan schoder fukushima c'est là
donc en fait ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
qu'au moment où l'allemagne accélère on
va dire sa sortie du nucléaire
au moment de fukushima en fait elle ne
fait qu'entériner un truc qui a démarré
des années avant au début des années
2000 et qui est un truc que merkel avait
essayé d'arrêter
juste avant fukushima puis avec
fukushima et a dit c'est long conflit
alors ici vous avez un pays qui pour le
moment n'a pas vraiment décidé d'arrêter
qui est la chine qui doit concentrer
aujourd'hui de mémoire pas loin de la
moitié des réacteurs en construction
dans le monde et qui comme vous le savez
probablement à démarrer un puis deux ep
r
le deuxième venant d'entrer en service
il ya quelques semaines ici vous avez la
corée du sud qui a on le verra un peu
plus tard une fraction assez
significative de son électricité qui
provient du nucléaire alors qu'il est
aussi récemment cette année en disant
est ce que je sors est-ce que je sors
pas ici vous avez le royaume uni alors
le royaume uni est un exemple
intéressant de pays qui a très envie
d'avoir du nucléaire qui on a
globalement actuellement plutôt de moins
en moins par défaut d'investissement
vous savez probablement que le pays que
le royaume uni est un pays a dit assez
libérale c'est à dire que on compte
beaucoup sur le privé pour faire des
choses est ce qu'on verra un peu plus
tard c'est que le nucléaire par
opposition au charbon et au gaz a la
particularité d'avoir une structure
économique dans laquelle il faut payer à
peu près tout avant de démarrer la
centrale vous avez une énorme part de
l'investissement est derrière une part
relative des coûts de fonctionnement qui
est très faible et quand vous êtes dans
un contexte dans lequel il faut payer à
peu près tout avant de démarrer la
centrale c'est un contexte dans lequel
dans le monde du capital privé ça aura
du mal à se faire
dit autrement le capital privé il aime
bien pas trop attendre pour voir le
rendement de l'argent arrivé en retour
donc quand il faut mettre plein d'argent
construire huit ans éventuellement 10
éventuellement 12 avant de commencer à
avoir un euro de chiffre d'affaires
c'est des trucs que le privé n'aime pas
du tout et donc le fait en grande
bretagne d'avoir mis dans le domaine
river comme dans beaucoup d'autres
endroits en europe mais encore plus tôt
que les autres
le système de production électrique a
conduit un défaut d'investissement s'il
s'est passé exactement le même processus
dans le train dans le bretagne
donc en ce moment ils sont en train de
faire machine arrière toute mais il
n'empêche que on paye ce défaut
d'investissement avec le fait que le
nucléaire que les rangs bretons aiment
bien a vu sa part baissé ici vous avez
un pays qui a également un parc
nucléaire significatif
vous verrez même après qu'il a une
singularité ce pays c'est la suède donc
la suède à une production nucléaire
conséquente et alors vous voyez ici
c'est une année où les suédois ont
décidé de sortir du nucléaire
ils ont fait un référendum et puis ils
ont dit qu'ils décident de sortir du
nucléaire
ça vous fait rire vous avez raison de
rire
en fait je le sens de le la contrepartie
de ce que j'ai dit sur le fait que le
nucléaire était un système qui était
très lent à s'installer c'est que c'est
aussi un système qui une fois qu'il est
en place
le nucléaires amorties et dans un truc
extrêmement pêcheurs là pour le coup
c'est très peu cher le nucléaire est
amorti s'en passer comme ça en disant on
va on va s'en débarrasser et puis en
fait on va le remplacer puis ça va pas
nous coûter cher et malheureusement
quelque chose de très difficile
enfin malheureusement ou heureusement je
ne sais pas mais c'est quelque chose de
très difficile et on verra quand fait
une fois qu'on a mis le doigt dans le
nucléaire c'est pas facile d'en sortir
rapidement ce qui est pas nécessairement
quelque chose de très gênant mais c'est
une caractéristique de qu'il faut avoir
en tête
ici c'est pareil
vous avez la suisse alors la suisse
cette année là elle fait un référendum
dans l'autre sens elles il y avait à
l'époque alors les suisses ils font
c'est assez rigolo ils font un pas en
avant un pas en arrière donc là où j'ai
cercle et en rouge c'est une année où il
dit oui disent on se donne le droit
avant il y avait un moratoire sur la
construction de nouvelles centrales
nucléaires c'est à dire le cadre
législatif en suisse et est de dire on
s'interdit de construire de nouvelles
centrales
puis en 2003 il vote en disant on
s'autorise éventuellement à construire
de nouvelles centrales si on veut
envoyer le résultat sur la production
tout à fait nul
juste ils ont dit où on en fait si on
veut la paix récemment ils ont voté dans
l'autre sens en disant on décide d'en
sortir
et d'ici à ce que je meure il n'est pas
complètement exclu qu'il recherche
d'avis au moins une fois ici vous avez
le cren alors l'ukraine est un pays que
vous connaissez à bout puisque c'est
dans ce pays qu'on a eu
charles habile à north shore mobile est
cerné cercle et l'a donc ce que peu de
gens savent c'est que après tchernobyl
ukraine a doublé sa production nucléaire
c'est assez amusant enfin je sais pas si
tu en as ville est amusant mais c'est
assez amusé cette anecdote est assez
amusant voilà donc la première premier
là c'était juste un rapide tour de piste
pour vous montrer qu'en ce qui concerne
le nucléaire
on a des évolutions selon les pays qui
sont contrastées qui ne correspondent
pas nécessairement à l'idée qu'on en a
dans un sens comme dans l'autre
alors maintenant on peut ranger les pays
qui font du nucléaire de plusieurs
manières la première manière qu'on peut
avoir de les ranger c'est de les ranger
par production en valeur absolue donc là
ce que vous voyez si on les range en
valeur absolue c'est que le premier pays
au monde en production nucléaire c'est
les états unis où nucléaire représente à
peu près 20% ne verra pas juste après de
la production électrique et ils ont une
production en valeur absolue qui reprit
pardon à peu près le double de la
production française pour plus semaine
ils ont une centaine de réacteurs en
activité dans ce pays après on peut
ranger par part dans la production
électrique alors à ce moment vous voyez
qu'effectivement la france arrive en
tête enfin vous avez quelques pays qui
arrive juste derrière avec la production
nucléaire qui représente une grosse
moitié de la production électrique donc
ils sont pas à 75 70 % mais ils sont
quand même à 50
après on peut les rangées encore d'une
autre manière et alors là je pense que
vous allez découvrir un truc que vous ne
saviez pas c'est en production en valeur
absolue par personne c'est à dire la
quantité de kilowattheures nucléaire
utilisée par personne et par an dans un
pays
hélas ce que vous voyez c'est que le
pays qui arrive en tête du classement
c'est pas du tout la france la suède
donc la suède est le pays au monde qui a
la plus grosse qu'à pas
cité installé par personne en nucléaire
est la plus grosse production annuelle
par personne en nucléaire
oui
oui ça veut aussi dire que ils ont des
consommations électriques par personne
très élevé absolument ils sont un peu
après ils sont un peu après la norvège
qui a une consommation de mémoire la
norvège et une consommation électrique
par personne qui est le triple de celle
de la france et les suédois se baladent
quelque part entre le double électrique
alors maintenant on va rentrer un peu
plus dans le détail la fission comme je
vous le disais c'est une manière
d'exploiter le fait que quand vous
casser un très gros noyau en deux ça va
vous libérer de l'énergie alors en
pratique il ya deux de première chose à
savoir c'est que la fission n'arrive
qu'à des noyaux qui ont un numéro
atomique supérieur à 89 et par ailleurs
ça n'est possible qu'avec des isotopes
un père donc par exemple l'uranium 238
ne fonctionne pas l'uranium 239 235 oui
le plutonium 239 fils yonne le plutonium
246 y est pas et c'est d'accord dont
vous avez un
les isotopes les isotopes père ne
d'officiels pas alors dans la majeure
partie des cas cette fiction il faut la
provoquer aléas c'est allé assez rare et
donc l'équation général d'une fiction
c'est ça c'est vous avez un noyau
d'uranium qui capturent à neutrons ça
lui donne une indigestion et il va
éclater en n morceaux alors n ces deux
gros x et y
plusieurs très petit quelques neutrons
et du rayonnement gamma donc ici vous
avez votre noyau fissiles de départ là
vous avez le neutron qu'il est capable
d'absorber alors après je rouge et le
dire tout de suite je sais pas si j'y
reviens plus tard ce neutre où tous les
noyaux fils ils ne sont pas capables de
fissionner avec tous les types de
neutrons vous avez deux catégories de
neutrons dans un réacteur nucléaire
vous avez les neutrons qu'on appelle
rapide les neutrons rapides c'est les
neutrons à l'énergie qu'ils ont juste
après la fission qui les a créés donc là
quand la fission a lieu et au moment où
elle a lieu
eh bien le neutron les nôtres ans qui
sont éjectés là ils ont une énergie de
quelques millions d'électron volts et
ces neutrons à quelques millions
d'électron volts
il ya des atomes fit signe qu'ils sont
capables de les absorber quand ils
passent à proximité dont vous avez le
federer de la capture de notre monde
quelle que soit la vitesse ils
l'attrapent et puis vous avez moi c'est
à dire que si ça passe trop vite à ma
portée je le sais rien d'en faire il
faut que ça allait lentement pour que je
sois capable d'aller le chercher
et ces neutrons qui passent lentement on
les appelle des neutrons thermique ça
veut dire qu'ils ont une énergie
cinétique de l'ordre de l'électro vote
beaucoup beaucoup moins que le million
d'électronvolts qu'ils ont au moment où
ils ont été créés vous avez donc la
création de ce qu'on appelle les
produits de fission donc les produits de
fission c'est les deux noyaux qui sont
issus de la fission de l'uranium des
neutrons 1,4 et du rayonnement gamma
alors voilà un exemple là vous avez un
noyau d'uranium qu'ils fissent yonne et
qui vous fait un noyau de krypton qui
soit dit en passant et gazeux donc dans
les produits de fission vous avez des
produits qui sont gazeux qui vont
spontanément à ce moment parce que
chimiquement et s'associe à rien sortie
à vouloir sortir du coeur vous avez du
baryum et puis ici vous avez 4 neutrons
et du rayonnement gamma donc c'est
l'équation général de la fission ça
ressemble toujours ça ressemble toujours
à ça vos produits de fission la nature a
décidé de faire un peu de biodiversité
dessus et donc vous n'avez jamais
exactement les mêmes à chaque fission
d'accord donc en fait les produits de
fission
ils sont il couvre une très très large
variété de numéros atomique comme vous
le voyez là cela étant ils sont quand
même centré sur deux il ya deux pics
il ya deux endroits où vous allez
préférentiellement retrouver vos
produits de fission vous allez en gros
les retrouver donc le
radium initial 1 ses 81 92 et donc en
gros vous allez retrouver 30 et 60 à
l'arrivée je dis bien en gros les
neutrons ça compte pas évidemment talent
numéro atomique donc à l'arrivée vous
allez retrouver 30 et 60 en ordre de
grandeur
donc vous allez retrouver en particulier
de l'yonne alors beaucoup de ces
produits de fission radioactif vers
trouvé de l'yonne du césium du strontium
du 70e et c'est les produits de fission
donc l'essentiel sont radioactifs avec
des demi vie qui vont de quelques enfin
d'une fraction de seconde
jusqu'à des milliers d'années donc il ya
un peu de il ya un peu de tout là dedans
l'essentiel des produits de fission
ondes et demi vit quand même qui
n'excède pas quelques dizaines d'années
la radioactivité des produits de fission
est quand même une radioactivité qui
décroît très vite on va le voir on va le
voir derrière ce que vous avez part donc
dans une fiction je sais pas si j'allais
de là dessus ce que vous allez créer
également quand vous avez changé d'avis
là dessus alors j'ai quand même vous en
parler rapidement quand les neutrons qui
sont créées par votre mission il y en a
une partie également qu'ils vont être
absorbées par les noyaux d'uranium que
vous avez dans le réacteur et en
particulier l'uranium 238 et qui vont
vous créez des épisodes des noyaux dont
le numéro atomique et au delà de
l'uranium en plutonium du proc tignes
hommes de l'américium du curium du etc
ces trucs là vous savez dans le tableau
de mendeleïev ça s'appelle des actinides
et souvent on appelle ça des activit
mineur parce que de fait ils sont
présents en petites quantités dans le
dans le dans la barre de combustible ça
dans la barbe
doxi d'uranium c'est actinides certains
vont officio des encours de réaction
soit dit en passant d'autres non et donc
vous allez récupérer dans le combustible
usé qu'on ressort à la fin je le disais
l'uranium 235 lui il
il aime bien les neutrons thermique donc
au moment où ils sont éjectés les
neutrons sont trop énergétique pour être
utilisé par un autre noyau d'uranium 235
encore l'idée c'est que 1 une fission
d'uranium 235 les neutrons qui sont émis
à l'occasion de cette fiction
vous vous en servier pour aller
fissionner ensuite d'autres noyaux
d'uranium 235 d'accord alors ça veut
dire deux choses cette histoire là ça
veut dire d'abord que le noyau qui
valait fissionner pendant le neutron qui
va aller fissionner un nouveau noyau
d'uranium 235 il doit pas aller trop
vite sinon ça marche pas ariane 235 il
est comme moi sont pas faits derrière
donc mis ses pas attraper les neutrons
qui vont trop vite et donc il faut le
ralentir dans un premier temps et alors
pour ça on va utiliser ce qui s'appelle
un modérateur et le modérateur c'est
juste jouer au billard avec le neutron
qui a été créée jusqu'au moment où il a
perdu suffisamment d'énergie pare-chocs
élastique sur d'autres petits noyaux
pour devenir un autre enterrement qui
vous savez que quand vous avez un choc
élastique entre deux objets de même
masse c'est là que vous perdez le plus
d'énergie cinétique dans l'objet
incident vous en rappeler de ça quand
vous avez un choc élastique sur un mur
parfait vous perdez rien d'accord donc
si vous avez une masse infinie en face
de vous choquer lastic vous perdez
absolument pas d'énergie le maximum
d'énergie c'est un exercice de mécanique
classique ça c'est un maximum d'énergie
vous allez le père quand vous tapez
contre un truc qui a exactement votre
pass si vous tapez contre un truc qui a
une masse microscopique vous perdez très
peu d'énergie aussi le truc par contre
l'autre truc part à toute vitesse mais
ça rapporte pas beaucoup d'énergie il
faut vous tapiez sur un truc qui a la
même masse que vous alors qu'est-ce qui
a la même masse que un neutron et bien
un autre neutrons ou un proton donc le
meilleur modérateur qu'on ait ces les
noyaux d'hydrogène de l'eau et donc
c'est la raison pour laquelle le
modérateur qu'on met dans un réacteur
excellence c'est juste de l'eau qui soit
dit en passant sert aussi de caloporteur
il sert aussi à évacuer la chaleur
du coup vous avez un élément de sécurité
passive c'est que si vous perdez une
calotte si vous perdez part dans lequel
au porteur et une fuite dans le circuit
par exemple certes vous n'êtes plus
capable de refroidir votre coeur mais
par ailleurs la fiction s'arrête c'est
un élément de sécurité passive important
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure que une
fission ça faisait entre 1 et 4 noteront
si vous voulez que votre réaction en
chaîne soit stable c'est à dire qu'au
cours du temps elle vous produisent
toujours la même quantité d'énergie
il faut que le 1 à 4 neutrons que vous
avez produit lors d'une fiction se
transforme en un neutron capturé par un
autre noyau d'uranium 235 et justin
si vous faites captures ci à partir d'un
noyau qui fit sione vous fait capturer
deux neutrons par deux autres noyaux
puis 4 puis 8 puis etc
ça s'appelle une bombe d'accord vous
avez un truc qui diverge très vite et
c'est soit dit en passant exactement le
principe de la bombe atomique dans la
bombe atomique
vous avez les premières fictions qui
font une réaction en chaîne qui va très
très vite et tout ça fait beaucoup
alors dans un réacteur ça peut pas aller
jusqu'au niveau d'une bombe atomique
mais ça peut quand même fiche le truc en
l'air c'est exactement ce qui s'est
passé à tchernobyl
et donc si vous voulez pas que ça arrive
eh bien il faut que quand vous avez plus
d'un neutron qui est créée par la
réaction de fission les neutrons
excédentaires soient absorbés par
quelque chose qu'il ya dans le réacteur
et qui vous permet de n'avoir à
l'arrivée qu'un seul nouveaux neutrons
pour fissionner un autre noyau d'uranium
235 et dont vous avez dans un réacteur
outre la matière fissile deux
constituants qui sont absolument
essentielles qui sont d'une part des
absorbeur de neutrons notamment le bord
et d'autre part un modérateur
typiquement de l'autre vous avez des
réacteurs dans lesquelles le modérateur
et du graphite
mais aujourd'hui on fait plus ça pour
plein de raisons dont le fait que si
vous perdez le caloporteur vous perdez
pas le modérateur et donc ça empêche pas
la réaction de continuer à se produire
donc là vous êtes dans un très mauvais
cap figure dans lequel la réaction
continue à se produire
et vous n'avez pas de quoi refroidir le
coeur donc les réacteurs à grafite et
tuant la ville
grafite vous en trouvez pas en
fonctionnement en france
je retrouvais en cours de démantèlement
mais pas en fonctionnement voilà donc le
but du jeu dans un réacteur
c'est que vous ayez en régime permanent
exactement un neutron capturé par
fission neutrons capturés pour
fissionner à un autre moyen aux
partitions si vous voulez faire monter
votre réacteurs en puissance
transitoirement vous allez passer de 1 à
1 000 000 1 un tout petit peu plus que 1
et si vous voulez calmer votre réacteurs
vous allez faire exactement l'inversé
c'est à dire que pendant un temps vous
allez passer de 1 à 0,9 9,9
jusqu'au moment où votre truc descend un
peu en puissance de là dedans vous avez
également l'émission de rayonnement
gamma est alors normalement les deux
troncs il en sort pas trop du réacteur
ce que vous avez absorber avant
par contre vous avez plein rayonnement
gamma qui sort du réacteur c'est pour ça
qu'un réacteur en fonctionnement vous
éviter d'aller vous promener à côté et
donc que vous avez une enceinte de
confinement qui est autour du donc le
réac tout ça c'est dans un tube en acier
dans une cuve en acier vous avez vos
assemblage d'oxydés d'uranium et l'eau
qui circule autour qui sert à la fois de
modérateur et caloporteur et tout ce
truc là qui vous crachent allègrement du
gamma émis dans un endroit à l'intérieur
d'un truc en béton où on est sûr que les
gamins vont pas aller se balader à
l'extérieur est comme ça y'a pas de
problème
alors si j'en parle de l'exactitude
alors les actinides donc j'y reviens
c'est le sait les produits plus lourd
enfin plus au delà de l'uranium dans
tableau périodique des éléments qui sont
créées par absorption successives de
neutrons et désintégration radioactive
donc là vous avez l'exemple par exemple
vous passez de l'uranium au plutonium en
ayant commencé par absorber un neutron
alors pardon avait à partir d'uranium
238 c'est comme ça que c'est comme ça
que ça marche parce que leur énième 235
encore une fois ci il absorbe les
neutrons officiel je vous rappelle que
dans un réacteur vous avez un mélange
des deux isotope 235 et 238 dans les
réacteurs français
uranium 235 au moment où vous enfourner
l'uranium c'est à peu près trois et demi
pour cent du total
donc ça veut dire 96 5% c'est d'uranium
238 vous avez des réacteurs dans le
monde qui fonctionne avec de l'uranium
naturel donc à 0 7 % d'uranium 235
mais à ce moment il vous faut de l'eau
bourde en général pour que ça marche
voilà donc la voilà un truc qui va vous
donner du plutonium alors le plutonium
peut fissionner et à ce moment vous
pouvez imaginer un réacteur dans lequel
vous avez qui est basé non pas sur la
fission de l'uranium 235 mais sur la
génération en continu de plutonium puis
la fission du plutonium
c'est ça qu'on appelle le surgénérateur
donc le surgénérateur typiquement phénix
et superphénix
c'est un réacteur dans lequel c'est
l'uranium 238 qui sert de combustible
sauf que il sert de combustible en ayant
besoin de deux trous donc c'est un truc
qui est plus compliquée à piloter parce
que vous avez vous devez tenir compte
c'est pas un truc instantanée vous devez
tenir compte des temps de formation et
dépendent décroissance radioactive pour
avoir du plutonium derrière le
l'avantagent par contre c'est que il ya
deux avantages à ceux assez réacteur là
le premier c'est que vous n'avez pas
besoin de modérateur
typiquement plutonium il sait fissionner
avec des neutrons lent et des refrains
des neutrons thermique et des neutrons
rapides
donc vous n'avez pas besoin de modérer
les neutrons corps et la deuxième c'est
que évidemment au lieu de brûler une
toute petite partie de l'uranium fois au
lieu de profiter d'une toute petite
partie parce que le relais est un terme
à trois plus ayem est un métal au lieu
d'utiliser une toute petite partie de
l'uranium qu'on trouve dans la nature
l'uranium 235 16 07 % de l'uranium qu'on
trouve dans la nature en utilisant des
réacteurs de ce type là vous utilisez la
totalité du radium qu'on trouve dans la
nature donc pas juste pour rien donc ça
veut dire que vous êtes capable de
multiplier par un facteur 2 100 en ordre
de grandeur le potentiel énergétique de
l'uranium qu'on trouve dans la nature
oui
alors typiquement superphénix s'était du
sodium ça dans les dents c'est rapide la
cdu sodium
vous avez également une famille de
réacteur qui fonctionne sur vous avez
plusieurs dessins là dedans ou un autre
c'est cette fondue donc en fait vous
avez un grand bain dans lequel tout est
mélangé enfin mais le les réacteurs
rapide qu'on a fait fonctionner
longtemps en france donc il ya eu un
réacteur industriels qui s'appelait
superphénix mais qui a été démantelée ça
qui a été arrêté au titre d'un compromis
politique est démantelée par contre y en
a un autre qui est des plus petits qui
s'appelait félix qui lui a fonctionné
pendant 30 ans de façon tout à fait
normal et on va dire mais qui a aussi
été arrêté et qui est en cours
enfin de démantèlement alors oui comme
ça je viens de vous le dire on peut
également se servir du thorium dans le
même
dans le même esprit donc le thorium
après absorption d'un autre on se
transforme en uranium 233 et l'uranium
233 et sicile donc c'est exactement le
même principe que avec le plutonium ce
qui veut dire qu'il ya deux couples dans
la nature qui peuvent servir à faire des
réacteurs nucléaire à neutrons rapides
et surgénérateur c'est uranium plutonium
ou thorium uranium mais c'est pas de la
mise au top 1 233 alors cela étant ces
éléments donc l'uranium 238 et le
thorium 232 comme il faut leur envoyer
des neutrons pour qu'il se mette à
fissionner ça veut dire que vous devez
avoir une source de neutrons pour
démarrer la réaction
donc en fait on ne peut pas démarrer un
réacteur nucléaire juste avec de
l'uranium 238 ou avec du thorium 232
on est obligés de démarrer avec un truc
qui fusionne naturellement dans
l'uranium 235 et c'est une fois que le
truc a démarré qu'on peut rajouter
derrière quelque chose de l'uranium 238
ou du thorium
232 donc en gros cdc des cycles qui
permettent d'augmenter le potentiel
d'une énergie nucléaire qui existe déjà
à base d'uranium 235 mais ça permet pas
de la remplacer en totalité
oui
[Musique]
ciba en partie le son c'est ce que j'ai
expliqué avant il le soit et c'est comme
ça que vous faites vos actinides une
partie le plutonium une partie va
fissionner dans le réacteur et une
partie va rester dans l'assemblage
quand vous le sortez en fin
d'exploitation on verra ça au moment des
déchets c'est exactement ce que je vous
ai montré alors j'y reviens si c'est pas
clair là d'accord je vous ai dit en fait
l'uranium qui est capable de monter dans
le tableau périodique des éléments c'est
l'uranium 238 en gros si assez simple
l'uranium 235 voulant rien de très
officiel
donc il peut pas monter en numéro
atomique puisqu'ils fonctionnent donc le
seul qui peut monter en numéro atomique
c'est l'uranium 238 il absorbe un autre
on après il vous faut une désintégration
bêta moins et du coup ça vous créant
protons dans le noyau est donc là ça
monte en numéro atomique et donc vous
allez vous allez monter comme ça on
mâche un crac crac crac
vous allez créer qu'est ce que je veux
dire du plutonium du neptunium du enfin
voilà vous avez créé des
des éléments qui sont l'amérique y
sommes dues curium machin comme ça
qu'ils s'appellent tous des actinides
alors dans les réacteurs actuels
une petite partie fils yonne mais dans
les déchets en sortie de réacteurs vous
allez en trouver quand même dans le
combustible usé en sortie des réacteurs
vous allez en trouver quand même dans
les dessins imaginés pour une partie de
la génération 4 eh bien il ya des gens
qui souhaitent qu'on fasse des réacteurs
dans lequel ces trucs là sont brûlés au
fur et à mesure qu'ils sont produits ce
qui est possible
alors parlons de génération justement
les générations c'est comme les versions
de windows
donc ça sur le même principe mais on dit
que ça s'améliore donc vous avez eu
génération 1 c'était les réacteurs à
uranium naturel graphite gaz
il y en a un certain nombre qui ont été
conçus en france ils ont tous été
arrêtés au moment où ce qui tenait lieu
d'autorités de sûreté
pas au sens où ça ne faisait pas
vraiment de la sûreté ou ça parce que ça
s'appelait pas autorité de sûreté a dit
edf ces trucs là on trouve que c'est pas
terrible donc vous bien vous mettez télé
vous faites tel et tel type de travaux
de mise en conformité ou s'arrêter et
des f a fait ses calculs et a dit on
arrête donc vous avez déjà eu en france
une première vague d'arrêt de réacteurs
avant terme
pas du tout pour des raisons politiques
pas du tout parce qu'on a dit c'est
hyper dangereux etc
et puis tu es les lecteurs soient très
bien qu'on les arrête pas du tout c'est
l'autorité de sûreté qui a dit ça ça ne
va pas donc travaux de mise en
conformité ou art est à dire la deuxième
réaction à la deuxième génération c'est
celle qu'on a aujourd'hui c'est
essentiellement des réacteurs en france
à eau pressurisée l'autre grand dessein
c'est les réacteurs à eau bouillante
la troisième génération c'est en fait du
de plus parce que ça change pas
tellement dans le concept
donc c'est le p r ou d'autres trucs de
cette nature et enfin il ya un certain
nombre de gens qui réfléchissent à la
génération d'après qui aujourd'hui est
un est un concept au sens où la
génération d'après on lui a donné un
cahier des charges
qui est exploité tout l'uranium ferme et
cycle c'est à dire ne pas sortir des
trucs qui peuvent encore servir du
combustible usé typiquement le plutonium
ça peut encore servir on peut encore
tirer de l'énergie du plutonium
donc c'est dommage de sortir du
combustible usé du réacteur
et puis d'aller mettre ça directement
dans un trou dans un stockage de déchets
100 recyclé s'en extraire de ce
combustible ce qu'on peut encore
utiliser valorisé à des fins
énergétiques et minimiser les déchets et
sécurité passive
enfin et surtout pas sifflé exactement
un réacteur donc un certain nombre de
trucs on vas y ça doit satisfaire à ça
ça et ça donc il ya déjà d un certain
nombre de concepts qui sont explorées en
ce moment voici un assemblage d'uranium
ces lieux si j'affiche tels que telles
qu'on les utilise dans les réacteurs
français
donc là vous avez des grands tubes en
eau en dire que nous sommes en alliage
de dirk omnium plus exactement à
l'intérieur duquel vous avez des
pastilles des oxydes d'uranium
c'est comme ça que c'est comme ça que
c'est enfourner l'eau peut circuler
entre ça s'appelle des crayons là c'est
petit c'est petit tube est ce que vous
remarquez c'est un truc intéressant à
savoir c'est que cet opérateur manipule
cet assemblage alors pas à mains nues
pour permettre des traces de graisse
mais sans aucune protection radiologique
donc en fait l'uranium au moment où il
est enfourné dans le réacteur nous
présente aucune radio toxicité
particulière corsa radioactivité
naturelle n'est pas tel que il faille
s'en protéger alors si on parle d
assemblage et de la manière dont c'est
fait
voilà en gros à quoi ça ressemble donc
l'uranium à qom toutes les ressources
que nous utilisons dans notre système
économique
elle est gratuite corps donc l'uranium
c'est gratuit ça a été fait par mère
nature
ou est-ce que ça a été fait par mère
pardon ah non lors du big man on n'avait
que des protons non mais j'ai entendu un
truc qui commence à se rapprocher pas
dans le soleil puisque le soleil pour
importer de l'uranium du soleil actuelle
sur terre c'est un peu compliqué mais
pardon dans les anciennes étoiles
exactement ça a été fait dans la
génération précédente des toiles si on
retrace l'univers l'histoire de
l'univers sur les 14 derniers milliards
d'années d'abord vous avez le big bang
une grande soupe de protons la première
génération des toiles et dans cette
première génération des toiles par
fusions successives vous avez tout le
tableau de mendeleïev qui se crée là
dessus les étoiles pour certaines
d'entre elles vous font des très belles
supernovae bazar tout ça dans l'espace
et une deuxième génération des étoiles
se forment
enfin il s'enflamme en permanence mais
je veux dire et ces poussières issues de
la première génération des toiles vont
pour partie allait se mettre en orbite
autour de la deuxième génération des
toiles se condenser et faire des
planètes telluriques
typiquement la terre donc pour faire une
terre avec 92 éléments du tableau de
mendeleïev faut attendre dix milliards
d'années après le big bang recettes de
cuisine qui prend un peu de temps et
c'est gratuit donc l'uranium est gratuit
comme tout le reste il faut juste aller
le chercher alors allé le chercher ça va
se faire comme pour tous les métaux dans
des endroits où il ya des concentrations
particulière vous trouver n'importe quel
métal n'importe où si vous n'êtes pas
regardant sur la concentration c'est à
dire que si j'extrais un mètre cube de
terre là dessous l'école des mines
je vais probablement y trouver tous les
éléments du tableau de mendeleïev mais
certains sont mais ils sont présents
dans des concentrations tels que j'en
ferai jamais rien donc quand ils sont
présents plus concentré qu'ailleurs ça
s'appelle une mine dans une mine vous
allez chercher de l'uranium
vous allez le chercher sous forme d'
occident en général comme mais vous avez
tout un tas d'autres trucs qui vous
intéressent absolument pas donc d'abord
vous sortez votre minerais et vous
concentrer ce qui vous intéresse
une fois que vous avez récupéré votre
radium vous allez faire une encore une
fois sous forme de site vous allez faire
une opération qui s'appelle
l'enrichissement pour les réacteurs
français alors l'enrichissement est un
mélange compliqué de chimie et de
physique
qui consiste à prendre
préférentiellement dans l'uranium
l'isotope 235 comme l'isotope 235 à très
exactement les mêmes propriétés
chimiques que l'isotope 238 puisque les
propriétés chimiques ça dépend du nombre
de protons ont donc d'électrons il faut
trouver un moyen pour séparer ses deux
isotopes qui n'est pas un moyen
chimiques
vous pouvez pas purifier chimiquement de
l'isotope 235 ça marche pas donc la
façon dont ça marche c'est avec des
centrifugeuses
alors notez bien ce que je vais vous
dire parce que c'est le grand débat sur
la prolifération une centrifugeuse c'est
quoi c'est un petit cylindre dans lequel
vous faites tourner de l'hexafluorure
d'uranium gaz et vous allez mettre une
écope à l'extérieur du cylindre et une
écope à l'intérieur du cylindre enfin
près de l'axé de rotation une écope
c'est un truc qui vous qui vous attrape
ce qui passe les coptes qui est après
après du bord du cylindre va vous
prendre préférentiellement de l'uranium
238 parce que à cause de la force
centrifuge ou centripète plus exactement
le 238 va avoir tendance à être
préférentiellement plus près du bord les
plus lourds et les coqs qui est près de
l'axé de rotation vous prend
préférentiellement d'u235 alors ce
préférentiellement c'est une fraction de
pour mille achats dans chaque centre et
du jeu donc il faut les mettre en
cascade les unes derrière les autres
jusqu'au moment où ça vous a enrichi
pour les coqs du centre votre uranium
préférentiellement en 235 à hauteur de
3% mais c'est exactement la même chaîne
qui permet de faire de l'uranium à 99
avec 99 % d'uranium 235
il suffit juste d'en avoir les milliers
et c'est avec ça que les pays qui
veulent accéder à l'armé nucléaire en
général s'équipent d'accord donc c'est
la même technologie que la technologie
civile de la chaîne du combustible sont
ce que si vous me réglez suffisamment ça
permet de faire une bombe alors quand le
but du jeu n'est pas de faire une bombe
heureusement donc vous séparer votre
radium et du coup une fois vous avez
enrichi votre uranium pour en gros pour
avoir une tonne d'uranium enrichi à 3 5%
il vous faut 5 tonnes d'uranium à 0 7%
derrière vous allez avoir une tonne
d'uranium propre à faire du combustible
et 4 tonnes d'uranium qui vous servent
entre guillemets à rien il s'appelle de
l'uranium appauvri alors l'uranium
appauvri est ce que vous savez qu'elle
était une des exploitations qu'on en a
fait à un moment exactement déleste pour
des voiliers de course parce que comme
c'est un métal extrêmement dense ça fait
des très grandes masses dans des petits
volumes
et ça quand vous faites un voilier
course dont vous allez mettre sa très à
quatre mètres sous la coque là et ça
vous fait des voix là je n'ai pas
spécialement dangereux une fois que vous
avez votre uranium enrichi donc vous en
faites des pesticides oxyde d'uranium
vous mettez ça dans les tubes en alliage
de zirconium 1 et ça vous fait les
assemblages que vous mettez dans
réacteurs vous laisser produire pendant
fissionner pendant quelques années
et puis une fois que ces sorties alors
là vous avez deux écoles en fonction du
pays où vous êtes vous avez des pays qui
disent je prends ça et ça c'est un
déchet et je le stock quelque part alors
aux états unis sous yucca mountain
les suédois y mettre ça dans des fûts en
cuivre il colle ça sous terre et en
france on a une autre école qui est de
dire on va faire du recyclage là dedans
parce qu'il ya une partie de ce qui s'y
trouve qu'on peut remettre dans des
assemblages convard et enfourner dans
des réacteurs corps c'est à ça que sert
d' usine de la hague et ce qui sert
vraiment à rien eh bien on s'en
débarrasse d'une autre manière c'est ça
le sait ça l'école française entre
guillemets donc vous avez deux écoles
dans le monde et ce qui ne sert plus à
rien là pour le coup s'appelle vraiment
des déchets alors pour avoir quelques
ordres de grandeur des masses en
présence pour un mégawatt heure
électrique
vous avez besoin de 10 kg 2
une règle qui vont vous donner quelques
grammes d'uranium donc vous voyez c'est
quand même la concentration oui la
valeur de trois et demi non non c'est ce
qui permet de piloter une réaction de
fission de façon confortable j'ai envie
de dire si vous en mettez 90% ça vous
fait une bombe
donc c'est incontrôlable et si vous en
mettez pas assez en fait ça vous fait
pas assez de neutrons et vous les voulez
vous n'êtes pas capable d'avoir votre
réaction en chaîne
donc je disais à partir de 10 kg 2
à faire à partir de 10 kg de minerai
vous à vous avez une grosse dizaine de
grammes un peu moins un peu plus une
petite vingtaine d'uranium donc vous
voyez que la concentration en uranium du
minerai est de l'ordre du pur mille
d'accord donc c'est pas des ehpad et
c'est pas des concentrations importantes
c'est l'heure du kg par tonne vous avez
un métal qui est présent encore à des
toners encore plus faible quand on
exploite c'est l'or l'or vous est
typiquement à quelques grammes par tonne
de minerai 10 grammes par tonne
donc là vous êtes quand même très au
dessus donc on va faire deux autres
affaires de l'uranium enrichi
et avec ça vous allez faire votre votre
mégawattheure ce que ça vous montre ce
genre de ce genre de diagrammes c'est
notamment encore une fois que vous avez
besoin de manipuler de toutes petites
quantités de matière pour faire des
grandes quantités d'électricité
c'est vraiment par excellence la
caractéristique du nucléaire bien
évidemment vous avez un rendement
énergétique de votre affaire exactement
comme pour le pétrole où vous devez
utiliser une partie de l'énergie
extraite pour pomper le pétrole
le raffiner le transporter en ce qui
concerne l'uranium
vous avez besoin d'une partie de
l'énergie fournie
alors pas sous la même forme parce qu'en
l'occurrence dans les mines c'est du
pétrole mais vous avez besoin d'une
partie d'énergie fournie pour faire
fonctionner la chaîne vous avez besoin
de la du diesel dans les engins de mines
de l'électricité dans l' usine
d'enrichissement etc et donc il ya une
question qui est quel est le rendement
énergétique de l'ensemble est ce que on
consomme 90 % d'énergie qu'on produit
dans la chaîne ou est ce que on en
consomme
juste une petite partie est donc ce que
vous montre ce graphique c'est qu'on
n'en consomment en fait juste une petite
partie le rendement typique de la de la
filière nucléaire
c'est de l'ordre de 1 pour 50 ou 1 %
c'est à dire que la fraction de
l'énergie qui est utilisé dans
l'ensemble du cycle pour permettre à
l'énergie nucléaire d'être produite
c'est de l'ordre de 1 à 2 % de l'énergie
produite
c'est de cet ordre là en fait c'est
extrêmement dépendant de la teneur en
minerai de la teneur en uranium par lots
du minerai ce que vous disent ce
graphique c'est que aux teneurs
actuelles
on se balade plutôt par là de minerais
mais si vous avez des minerais
suffisamment pauvres eh bien il faut
charrier une telle quantité de terre et
purifier une telle quantité de matière
que vous pouvez évidemment vous
rapprocher d'un rendement qui serait de
l'ordre de leur bel assez logarithmique
un oui
donc en gros il faut perdre un facteur
100 dans la teneur en uranium du minerai
pour que votre affaire commence à ne
plus être intéressante
donc on en est évidemment encore
extrêmement loin par ailleurs quand vous
avez comme vous avez besoin de toutes
petites quantités de entre guillemets
combustible pour produire des grandes
quantités d'électricité
le nucléaire est une industrie qu'on
appelle à coûts fixes
dit autrement l'essentiel du coût
économique de production du nucléaire
c'est dans la construction de la
centrale et dans la construction des
installations amont et aval qui
permettent de fonctionner les coûts
variables et notamment les coûts de
combustible sont des coûts extrêmement
faible dans la chaîne dit autrement une
fois que vous avez construit votre
centrale qu'elle fonctionne ou qu'elle
fonctionne pas ça vous coûte la même
chose et en cela c'est exactement la
même structure de coûts qu'une éolienne
ou un panneau solaire une éolienne ou un
panneau solaire une fois que vous l'avez
construit ça vous coûte quasiment plus
rien en face ils éoliennes fall et la
maintenir à peu de temps en temps
panneaux solaires fois les lui passer un
petit coup d'épongé pour enlever la
poussière de temps en temps mais
globalement
vous avez des coûts de maintenance qui
sont faibles et l'essentiel du coût et
dans la construction du dispositif
initial et le nucléaire c'est exactement
pareil
l'essentiel du coût et dans la
construction du dispositif initial et
alors là je vais refaire un tout petit
peu de microéconomie quand vous avez un
dispositif où vous devez mettre tout
l'argent d'abord et avoir des clients et
des recettes
ensuite le coût auquel vous allez leur
vendre le mégawattheure va dépendre de
deux critères de manière absolument
centrale 1 le coût de construction vous
comprenez bien que si vous construisez
pour deux fois plus cher toutes choses
égales par ailleurs vous vendrez pour
deux fois plus cher mais ça dépend
également d'un autre élément qui est
absolument centrale et qui pour ceux
d'entre vous qui ont vu passer un crédit
immobilier
ça vous rappellera des souvenirs qui est
ce qu'on appelle le coût de l'argent
c'est à dire le taux d'intérêt que vous
devez payer soit votre actionnaire soit
votre banquier pour l'argent qui vous a
été fourni pour construire la centrale
donc en gros quand vous construisez une
centrale votre argent ils tombent pas du
ciel
votre argent il vient de deux sources et
de sources seulement votre actionnaire
et votre banquier donc votre actionnaire
investi dans le projet il investit dans
la centrale puis il très bien j'ai mis
mon argent mais tous les ans je veux que
ça me rapporte des dividendes
je gagnais de l'argent et votre banquier
va vous dire exactement la même chose je
viens vous prêtez de l'argent mais à
condition que tous les ans vous me payer
les intérêts sur la partie vous m'avez
pas encore remboursé
et alors ce que vous dit le graphique
que je vous affiche maintenant c'est
combien ça vous coûte en euros par
mégawattheure pour une centrale qui de
mémoire était à 5000 euros le kilo watt
installé en fonction du loyer de
l'argent donc ce que vous voyez c'est
que si on vous prête l'argent
gratuitement
même avec un de paix est reconstruit
cher et hors délai et bien le
remboursement de l'investissement c'est
20 euros le mégawattheure corps donc ce
n'est pas beaucoup
par contre si vous avez un banquier ou
un actionnaire qui vous dit ouais moi je
considère que c'est vachement risqué
cette histoire donc je vais vous
demander 10 % donc tout l'argent que
vous me devez encore ou que gérer ce que
le lait s'est investi dans la boîte
eh bien tant qu'il est là c'est 10 % par
an que vous devez me payer c'est le
rendement du capital et bien si vous
êtes à 10% la part de l'investissement
dans le coup du mégawattheure frise les
100 euros donc une très grosse
différence entre le nucléaire pas cher
et le nucléaire cher c'est tout bêtement
combien est-ce que les actionnaires et
les banquiers vont vous demander en taux
d'intérêt sur l'argent qui vous est
nécessaire pour construire la centrale
et avec ce petit graphique vous pouvez
faire le calcul inverse en ce qui
concerne les 'points vous avez pas
qu'ils aient entendu parler d'une clé
politis y ait l'épaule c'est une
centrale que les anglais sont en train
de construire et c'est une filiale d'edf
qui est en train de le faire donc cdf
énergie qui est le plus gros électricien
anglais une filiale d'edf qui est en
train de construire est alors dans le
milieu des gens qui s'intéressent à la
question électrique
les gens qui n'aiment pas le nucléaire
vous explique que c'est horriblement
cher et que les pognes parce que ça va
produire des mégawattheure à 110 euros
alors rendez vous contre 110 euros c'est
très cher beaucoup plus cher que
d'autres trucs en fait avec ce petit
graphique vous êtes capable de savoir
que ça vaut 110 euros le mégawattheure
parce que les actionnaires et les
banquiers de vente 10% rendement sur
capital investi et c'est exactement ça
tu restes vous posez la question c'est
exactement symptômes oui
parce que la part du ce que je veux dire
parce que la part du capital dans la
structure de coûts n'est pas la même en
fonction et la longue la durée de
construction et la durée de vie ne sont
pas la même non plus donc en fait ça
dépend également de la durée de
construction de la diorite liste c'était
en fait j'aurais dû effacer les autres
courses était pas tellement le sujet le
sujet c'est de montrer que en ce qui
concerne le nucléaire ça augmente très
très vite avec avec le loyer de l'argent
avec le taux auquel on vous demande de
rembourser l'argent
par ailleurs le rendement des capitaux
et c'est aussi pour ça que le nucléaire
même pas l'investissement privé
le rendement des capitaux qu'on vous
demande classiquement dans une
entreprise cotée en bourse se balade aux
alentours de 10 12%
encore oui si on vous demande un
rendement sur capital investi aux
alentours de 10 12%
et bien si vous êtes une entreprise
cotée en bourse et vous faites du
nucléaire vous savez pas le faire à
moins de 100 euros mégawattheure et
c'est juste ça le sujet parce que si
vous êtes une société d'état et qu'on
vous demande 0 eh bien vous savez le
faire alors hors coûts variables
vous savez le faire pour beaucoup moins
cher que ça le nucléaire comme je le
disais tout à l'heure ne suppose pas
d'oxydé des atomes de carbone pour
obtenir la source primaire d'énergie du
coup c'est une énergie dont le les
émissions de co2 par mégawattheure sont
faibles alors il ya quand même un peu de
co2 en analyse de cycle de vie parce que
comme je le disais tout à l'heure il ya
des engins de mines qui utilise du
diesel
il ya du transport du minerai enfin du
transport du combustible
il ya des gens qui viennent bosser à la
centrale en voiture il faut construire
la centrale est donc couler du béton et
donc il faut le faire donc des
cimenteries des aciéries il faut traiter
les déchets à laval donc enfin on va
donc tout ça fait que vous avez quand
même des petites émissions de co2 à
droite et à gauche
mais quand même vous voyez que c'est des
émissions qui sont significativement
plus faible que celle des modes
concurrents fossiles notamment l'inite
charbon et gaz
vous voyez qu'on est significativement
en dessous d'eux
des valeurs qu'on a pour ce mode là
alors maintenant je vais vous montrer
non ça je peux augmenter parce que j'ai
pas le temps je vais vous montrer ça
plutôt d'après je vous montre à la même
chose dans le coût carbone est
essentielle il est dans l'amont du cycle
et dans la mine d'aminé l'enrichissement
oui assez carbon capture and storage
c'est le truc dont j'ai parlé la
dernière fois alors le coup co2 du
démantèlement est très faible parce que
le démantèlement s'est essentiellement
passée avec une scie à diamant et
découpez le truc quand vous faites du
démantèlement vous n'avez pas besoin de
fonte de l'acier
vous n'avez pas besoin de faire du
ciment vous n'avez pas besoin d'avoir
des engins de mines qui vous extrait une
tonne pour récupérer 10 kg de minerai à
l'arrivée donc en fait c'est s'aider
opération qui demande beaucoup de temps
parce qu'elles sont très réglementées
mais en termes de flux physiques
associés et donc d'émissions de co2
associées à ces opérations la céder
toutes petites quantités
c'est pareil c'est pas ça change pas les
ordres de grandeur en gros le
démantèlement d'une installation
industrielle compliqué que soit soir
centre indre un réacteur nucléaire ou
une win raffinerie c'est 10 à 15 % du
coût de construction
c'est très très dépendants du niveau de
réglementation applicable donc plus plus
vous avez une réglementation qui est
contraignante
un exemple typique c'est n'importe quoi
qui sort d'une centrale à l'arrêt est
considéré comme un déchet nucléaire
d'accord indépendamment du fait que si
je mesure la radioactivité ce soit
effectivement contaminés ou pas bon ben
vous avez une réglementation à la
chinoise pragmatique qui dit je mesure 6
et contaminé je stocke si c'est pas
contaminer ça va bien et la
réglementation française c'est ça sort
du site ces déchets je traite en tant
que tel
vous voyez simplement 7,7 différents
cela augmente le coût et augmenté les
délais pour la pierre des trucs comme ça
vous en avait pléthore dans dans ce
genre d'opération vous avez alors je
vous en ai pas pas j'en parlais pas
pendant ce court mais
vous avez une centrale aux états unis
qui a été ce qu'on appelle retourner au
gazon c'est à dire qu'à la place de
l'ancienne centrale vous avez
aujourd'hui effectivement un champ corps
qui s'appelle maignan qui donc comme un
yankee en américain et mind comme l'état
du maine donc allé voir si ça vous
intéresse et en fait l'opération de
démantèlement du réacteur a été fait
pour 450 millions de dollars si ma
mémoire est bonne sachant que le
réacteur 9 août 5 milliards enfin trois
oui on est dans ses ordres la 10 15% et
je tiens du patron ne peut pas lui-même
à qui j'avais posé la question que pour
une raffinerie c'est pareil c'est 10 à
15%
c'est pareil c'est un truc compliqué
avec des tas de produits que vous n'avez
pas envie de voir se balader partout
dans la nature même ordre de grandeur
voilà donc là je vous ai expliqué grosse
maille quel était le principe de
l'énergie nucléaire donc encore une fois
je répète pour le couple du sang voilà
peut-être pas tout écouté jusqu'à
maintenant
donc c'est une manière d'obtenir des
grandes quantités d'énergie avec très
peu de matières sans combustion ça à cet
avantage là ça évidemment des
inconvénients dont je vais vous parler
maintenant ça les inconvénients et
contrepartie il ya quelque chose
d'intéressant c'est que le nucléaire en
france pour des raisons que je vais
toujours pas complètement explicité à
une très très forte asymétrie entre les
risques perçus et les risques réels
c'est à dire que c'est un domaine dans
lesquelles les gens ont très très peur
et vous allez voir que ça se quantifie
le fait qu'ils en aient très peur et se
sont plaints de boue et de pleins
d'idées qui sont pas conformes au fait
vous allez voir aussi que ça se
quantifie d'une n'existe pas
nécessairement dans les autres
industries
alors vous avez ici lire et celle qui a
posé
c'était en 2014 mais il faut savoir que
ces sondages l'art depuis que je les
suis ça varie assez peu d'une année sur
l'autre a demandé aux français si un
certain nombre de choses étaient
risquer un peu risqué ou pas risquer du
tout donc là c est ce que vous pensez
que les risques sont élevés moyennement
élevée faible ou bien vous en avais pas
la moindre idée
alors voilà on vous demande ça pour le
tabagisme etc
la drogue l'alcoolisme en faveur des
trucs pour lesquelles les gens ont une
idée raisonnablement fiable on va dire
du fait que c'est quand même pas
terrible
et puis voilà quelques sujets qui
concerne le nucléaire est envoyé pour
les déchets radioactifs est bien la
population française considère que c'est
plus risqué que tout ce que vous avez à
droite là d'accord donc la population
française a plus peur des déchets
radioactifs que de l'obésité chez les
jeunes que des accidents de la route que
du sida que du terrorisme que des ogm
que des maladies professionnelles que
les installations chimiques que des
produits alimentaires que des
innovations et c'est que des incendies
de forêts risque médicaux voilà donc
tous ces trucs là pareil pour alors bon
les centrales nucléaires c'est pas très
précis seulement il aurait fallu être
peut-être un peu plus précis les vents
les retombées en france de tchernobyl
dont je vous parlerai aussi voyez c'est
considéré comme étant plus risqué que
tous ces trucs là alors ça c'est la
perception de la population
et maintenant on va regarder ce que vous
disent les chiffres alors les chiffres
vous disent que le tabac fait de l'ordre
de quelques dizaines de milliers de
morts prématurées par an alors pour ceux
d'entre vous qui fument dans cette salle
bonne nouvelle
pas tout de suite encore que deuxième
vous pouvez très bien choper une
hémiplégie un avc donc un accident
vasculaire cérébral et une hémiplégie
à votre âge voilà j'ai connu ça avant
apparemment personnellement mais je les
ai vus se produire donc je sais que
c'est possible
le voilà donc ça ça fait soixante dix
mille morts par envoyer la drogue
alors les déchets nucléaires à ce jour
on fait zéro mort
absolument personne n'est mort d'avoir
ingéré
c'est cette fête tombait un flux de
déchets nucléaires sur la tête alors
l'obésité il disait chez les jeunes bon
alors si on considère que les jeunes
finiront par être moins jeunes ce dont
je suis un exemple parmi d'autres ça
finira par faire quelques dizaines de
milliers de morts par an oui les
accidents de la route
c'est monté jusqu'à 20000 morts par an
au milieu des années 70 bon maintenant
c'est en nombre de vendeurs dix fois
moins le sida ces quelques centaines le
terrorisme ces quelques dizaines enfin
en moyenne on va dire là vous avez des
nouveaux héros les maladies
professionnelles des accidents du
travail ces quelques centaines alors là
les accidents domestiques josemi 10000
c'est plutôt un bilan fait donc par
exemple les escaliers en france sont
considérablement plus de morts que les
déchets nucléaires
ça fait à peu près autant de morts par
an que les accidents de la route le
radon est ce que vous savez ce que c'est
que le radon alors oui c'est un
alors cet isotope là et radioactifs
absolument et c'est un gaz qui apparaît
par décroissance radioactive
si ma mémoire est bonne du radium et que
vous trouvez
alors qu'ils provoquent un surplus de
cancer du poumon et c'est un gaz qui est
à décroissance radioactive assez rapides
donc si vous êtes et il apparaît
préférentiellement sur les massifs
granitiques et dans les habitations mal
ventilée donc si vous avez vous même ou
vos parents ou grands parents oncles
tantes etc
une maison mal à la cave mal ventilée en
bretagne par exemple ou en auvergne a ni
traînez pas trop longtemps encore
parce que c'est des gens n'allaient pas
vous y installer logement quotidien donc
c'est voilà donc on inhale son on inhale
ce gaz est derrière il va vous bazarder
des particules alpha dans les alvéoles
qui n'aime pas ça donc vous voyez ici
que le la hiérarchie des risques n'est
pas du tout perçue comme étant conforme
aux données d'observation oui là partent
tous les déchets nucléaires sont à la
hague dans une piscine dans les
centrales nucléaires c'est pareil vous
avez aujourd'hui les travailleurs du
nucléaire sont surveillés avec des
dosimètres et vous avez une limite
légale qui est 20 millisieverts par an
voilà je sais pas si je vous avais déjà
posé la question est ce que vous savez
quel est le salarié français le plus
irradiés pas mal il s'appelle comment
thomas pesquet thomas pesquet et le
salarié français le plus irradiés de la
totalité des gens qui sont payés dans ce
pays thomas pesquet prend quand il va
faire un séjour de quelques mois dans la
station spatiale internationale que je
dise pas de bêtises neuf fois la dose
maximale admissible pour un travailleur
du nucléaire après la deuxième catégorie
a effectivement été cité ces deux
personnels navigants
aérien qui prend chaque année entre le
quart et la moitié de la dose maximale
admissible pour un travailleur du
nucléaire
il emporte dosimètres donc voilà donc
c'est surveillé
c'est soit dit en passant le personnel
aérien navigant n'a pas non plus plus de
cancers que la moyenne
oui enfin pas à cause des rayonnements
ionisants en tout cas peut-être d'autres
conduites à risque je ne sais pas mais
la cause des rayonnements ionisants
c'est sûr que non oui
je vous en parlerai plus tard oui si
mais je ne suis pas complètement sûr que
s'il n'y avait pas ces composés là ça
serait totalement innocents tués voilà
une autre asymétrie intéressante sur la
perception des français et les risques
réels
là on a demandé aux français est ce que
le nucléaire contribue ou pas aux
émissions de gaz à effet de serre alors
vous voyez les gens qui sont en rouge
foncé disent beaucoup les gens qui sont
en rouge clair disent un peu voilà et
alors les jeunes filles dans cette salle
sont l'archétype des gens qui pensent
que ça contribue énormément donc tous
les gens dans cette salle d'une manière
générale le pense plus que la moyenne
puisque vous êtes jeune et que les
jeunes ne pensent plus que la moyenne et
les femmes le pense plus que les hommes
donc les jeunes ça dans cette salle
alors trêve de plaisanterie vous voyez
que là on est sûr je vois comment il
faut appeler ça une dissonance cognitive
vous avez une dissociation totale entre
un fait parce que là pour le coup c'est
sûr que casser un noyau de métal en deux
c'est pas oxydée un atome de carbone
c'est sûr que c'est pas la même chose
confie alors une explication possible de
la part des gens qui suivent ça c'est
que comme l'image d'epinal de nucléaire
c'est un truc qui fument bas les gens se
disent ce truc là c'est chaud ça fume
donc ça a contribué au réchauffement
complètement idiot de se dire ça une
autre explication possible c'est de se
dire comme dans notre pays on n'arrête
pas de dire il faut s'occuper du
changement climatique et par ailleurs il
faut fermer des réacteurs nucléaires bas
les gens boucle la boucle en disant
c'est que les réacteurs doivent
contribuer au changement climatique
suivent deux possibilités chez moi
oui mais les émissions humaines sont
totalement marginal dans le cycle
naturel de l'eau je sais pas si vous
étiez là où mon du cours sur le
changement climatique mais j'en ai parlé
pardon non mais j'en ai parlé de la lune
est une des sources de vapeur d'eau qui
modifient significativement le climat
local c'est le barrage d'assouan en
egypte
parce que là on a fait une sources
d'évaporation absolument massive par
rapport à la surface du pays mais les
tours de réfrigération des centrales
thermiques d'une bonne note que je sois
nucléaire ou à charbon c'est totalement
inutile au desk dans le sur une terre
qui est couverte aux deux tiers océans
voilà alors le les inconvénients ou les
contreparties on va dire du nucléaire on
va en parler un tout petit peu
maintenant les voici j'ai commencé par
dernier il ya la question évidemment des
ressources puisque il ya un inventaire
de départ d'uranium sur terre exactement
comme il ya un inventaire de départ de
minerai de cuivre de diamants de platine
et donc la question c'est combien y en a
alors comme pour tout métal qu'il
combien il y en a dépend de quelle est
la quantité de ressources énergétiques
et donc de ressources économiques que
vous êtes prêt à mettre dans
l'extraction de ce métal puisque vous
avez des dépôts plus ou moins riches et
comme je le disais si vous avez une
énergie infinie et bien il ya de
l'uranium sous le sol de l'école des
mines
d'accord je peux aller je peux y aller
et l'extraire donc une ressource minière
c'est toujours quelle quantité pour
quels moyens mise en face et alors les
moyens mis en face on a coutume de les
assimiler au prix payé 1 en a coutume de
tout ramener à d euros en dix ans c'est
comme ça qu'on a le meilleur proxy donc
ce que vous disent ce graphique c'est
quelque part que vous avez dans les
métaux quelque chose qui ressemble à ce
que vous avez dans le pétrole avec du 1p
et 2p et 3p
est ce que vous devez retenir comme
ordre de grandeur c'est que si on va
racler tous les fonds de tiroirs qu'on
peut trouver à droite et à gauche on a
de l'ordre de quelques dizaines de
millions de tonnes d'uranium disponibles
sur terre ou accessibles sur terre vous
en avez aujourd'hui qu'on n'exploite pas
par exemple y en a dans les phosphates
vous en avez dans l'eau de mer dans
l'aude mais on peut le récupérer avec
des polymères qu'on laisse tremper
c'est donc vous avez quelques dizaines
de millions de tonnes alors quelques
dizaines de millions de tonnes est ce
que c'est suffisant pour qu'on colle des
centrales nucléaires partout et qu'on
soit débarrassé des problèmes à la fois
de disponibilité des combustibles
fossiles et du changement climatique
finalement c'est ça la règle de trois
qui est intéressant ce faire alors la
réponse est oui et non c'est à dire que
si on considère que l'on reste sur les
réacteurs ungg uranium 235 comme
aujourd'hui
et bien si vous les augmenter de 5 ou 10
% par an pour faire face aux problèmes
que j'ai évoquées dues aux combustibles
fossiles
avant la fin du 21e siècle vous avez
quand même un prêtre de ressources par
contre si vous passez à partir de ce
parc de réacteurs là qui sert à démarrer
les réacteurs de la génération d'après
et que vous passez en cycle fermé dans
dans les réacteurs de génération 4 là
vous vous y arrivez c'est à dire que la
ressource n'est plus un sujet majeur
donc en gros le sujet central pour un
nucléaire entre guillemets durable au
sens de sa doit contribuer
significativement aux problèmes évoqués
précédemment
c'est de passer à la génération d'après
qui exploite l'essentiel du de l'uranium
ou qui exploite le thorium qui est
quatre fois plus abondant que l'uranium
et à ce moment là densité énergétique du
matériau est telle dans la fission que
on a plus de problème de ressources
d'ici à ce que l'humanité c'est
peut-être parce que font finira par
mourir de quelque chose voilà voilà ce
que vous dit en gros ce graphique après
on a un sujet en ce qui concerne le
traitement à l'aval du cycle 1 c'est à
dire les déchets alors jusqu'à
maintenant j'ai utilisé le oui pas non
non je vous dis à par l'uranium appauvri
a servi à faire des quilles de bateaux
et des flèches anti char mais sinon il
n'y a pas tellement d'autres
c'est pas décoratifs se sent pas
spécialement bon n'en fait pas des
oeuvres d'art c'est ma question je
l'étais ans aurait pu servir à autre
chose
oui donc j'ai utilisé le terme
combustible jusqu'à maintenant mais il
faut bien voir que combustible en fait
c'est un terme impropre puisque ça brûle
pas ça aficion alors on rassemble âge
quand je rentre j'ai donc de l'uranium à
3 4 % d'uranium 235 je le sors au bout
de quelques années
alors j'ai encore de l'uranium mais
beaucoup moins est ce que vous voyez
c'est que la fraction d'uranium 235 a
considérablement baissé
mais il reste encore mais il en reste
encore j'ai créé du plutonium
alors ce plutonium soit dit en passant
il y en a une partie qui est fissile
c'est du plutonium 239 du plutonium 241
et j'en ai une partie qui n'est pas fils
il s'est plutôt nième 240 voir le 242
j'ai tous ces isotopes de plutonium dans
le plutonium que je sors d'une centrale
or il se trouve et je vous dis ça en
passant il se trouve que le plutonium
qui sert à faire les bombes c'est
plutonium 239 à l'exclusion de tous les
autres
donc le plutonium que je sors en
retraitement d'une centrale nucléaire
est totalement impropres à faire une
bombe pour pouvoir faire des bombes
il faut que le plutonium viennent d'un
assemblage qui est resté simplement
quelques mois dans le coeur du réacteur
c'est pour ça que les centrales qui sont
plutôt ni gêne pour faire des bombes
c'est des centrales qu'on appelle à des
chargements en continu c'est à dire que
c'est des centrales dans lesquels en
cours de fonctionnement je peux chargé
du combustible est déchargé du
combustible est soit dit en passant
tchernobyl c'était exactement ce type de
centrale et c'est pour ça qu'il y avait
des particularités dans le
fonctionnement et dessins de ces 30
salle qui la rendait par ailleurs
beaucoup plus dangereuse que les
centrales qu'on a en france c'est parce
qu'elle avait cet usage là qui était de
chargement enfin de fabrication
plutonium et donc qu'elle avait la
possibilité d'être chargées et
déchargées enfantine et vous avez les
fameux produits de fission
c'est à dire les les éléments qui sont
centrés autour de numéro atomique 30 et
comme je le disais et qui n'ont pas déjà
disparu dans le coeur du réacteur
alors pour s'appeler ses produits de
fission
c'est intéressant où les déchets
nucléaires c'est intéressant de les
comparer à l'ensemble des déchets que
produisent des hommes parce qu'il n'y a
pas qu'avec le nucléaire ont produit des
déchets pour fabriquer le t-shirt ou la
robe que vous portez il a fallu faire
des déchets aussi les déchets
industriels pour faire vos binettes il a
fallu faire des déchets et pour faire
vos chaussures il a fallu faire des
déchets et pour faire l'école des mines
il a fallu faire des déchets d'accord
donc 26 et il ya longtemps
donc la prochaine fois qu'on changera le
faux plafond il faudra faire des déchets
donc on fait des déchets pour absolument
tout dans notre activité est la question
c'est est ce qu'on en fait plus ou moins
avec sa part personne je dis bien par
personne en france nous faisons 2,5
tonnes vous les voyez pas évidemment ils
sont pas chez nous de déchets
industriels par an oui
à cause d'eux et il ya même ces deux
à cause d'eux égale mc2 l'énergie qui a
été libéré par la fission correspond à
un défaut de masse a le défaut de masse
n'est pas de zéro sinon il y aurait zéro
énergie bon oeil à la mc2 6ème il ya 2 0
c'est au carré a beau être très très
grand e et quand même égal à zéro donc
ses défauts de masse la différence entre
les deux le oui donc les déchets
industriels qu'on fait c'est deux tonnes
et demie par personne et par an en
france c'est la contrepartie encore une
fois de la fabrication de tous les
objets que vous achetez au cours d'une
une jambe et là dedans il y en a cent
qui demandent un traitement des filières
spécial encore un peu les déchets
toxiques les déchets nucléaires par
personne tous types de déchets confondus
c'est moins de 1
et là dedans ce qu'ils sont vraiment
emmerdant donc ce que on va aller
stockés à 6 g au corps à burlats dans la
meuse cela ils font quelques grammes par
français et par an d'accord donc c'est
l'équivalent d'une ou deux pièces de
deux euros par français et par an donc
retenu s'est dit d'une autre manière que
pour 40 ans d'activité on en fait
quelques milliers de mètres cubes ou
encore par an on en fait le volume d'un
appartement de trois pièces d'accord
donc la production totale de déchets en
mer dans les déchets à haute activité et
à longue durée de vie on en fait
l'équivalent d'un appartement 3 pièces
de 100 mètres cubes par personne et par
an d'accord 200 mètres cubes
c'est en ordre de grandeur ici on a quoi
on a dix mètres sur 10 bah on les a dans
ces pièces là on n'a même plus d'accord
donc la production annuelle de déchets
nucléaires emmerdant en france c'est le
volume de ces pièces non pour la totale
pour la totalité de la france tout à
fait librement par personne ça fait
beaucoup pour la totalité de la france
donc c'est des trucs en verlan mais
c'est pas des gros volumes
alors où est ce qu'ils sont stockées ces
déchets nucléaires ça dépend de leur
radiotoxicité donc pour ceux qui sont
pas très radioactifs genre de truc qu'on
fait on fait comme des abeilles à
l'envers on fait des alvéoles
on vient coller les déchets là dedans
alors dans les déchets de faible
activité vous avez par exemple les
combinaisons qui ont été utilisées par
les opérateurs qui travaillent à la
hague
voilà ça c'est un exemple de déchets de
faible activité vous avez des résidus
vous avez des résidus de traitement
donc là par contre dans le combustible
usé là vous n'avez pas de déchets de
faible activité
ça ça repart dans le cycle du
combustible
ça a également et ça ça va directement
colis vitrifiés d'accord donc les
déchets de faible et moyenne activité
ils viennent pas de là ils viennent
d'ailleurs
donc voilà le genre de stockage qu'on a
et puis une fois que ces trucs là sont
refermées on met un gros tas de terre
par dessus et on en parle plus alors je
vous présente qui baigne dans la manche
sûrement pas au titre des activités
actuelles il ya eu des déchets immergé
en mer je sais plus exactement les mêmes
mais ça fait très chaud au moins 40 ans
s'est arrêtée là je vous présente le
plus vieux site de stockage de déchets
au monde
quel âge at il
il a deux milliards d'années absolument
vous avez ici
lamido clos au gabon dans laquelle a
fonctionné naturellement donc les hommes
n'ont même pas inventé ça où il est
brillant ingénieur des mines n'ont même
pas inventé l'énergie nucléaire c'est
ballot l'énergie nucléaire a été inventé
tout seul par la nature il ya deux
milliards d'années dans la mine dauphin
dans des réacteurs naturelles dont vous
en avez eu un exemplaire dans cette mine
d'uranium
alors je vous la fais très rapide il ya
deux milliards d'années comme la double
vie de l'uranium 235 ses 7 à 800
millions d'années
la teneur en uranium 235 dans l'uranium
naturel ces trois et demi pour cent ça
tombe bien c'est comme dans les
réacteurs dans l'uranium enrichi
aujourd'hui et dans cette mine vous avez
les infiltrations d'eau dont vous avez
le modérateur qui arrivent spontanément
par dessus donc vous avez de l'uranium
enrichi le modérateur craque
la réaction de fission se met en route
évidemment il faut que la réaction de
fission s'est mise en route ça chauffe
du coup ça valorise l'eau du coup il ya
plus de modérateur du coup ça s'arrête
du coup leur revient du coup ça repart
etc et donc vous avez un réacteur pulsé
comme ça qui a fonctionné pendant des
centaines de milliers d'années qui vient
des centaines de milliers d'eric et il a
fait des déchets il a fait des produits
de fission dont il a fait des déchets
question où sont passés les déchets à la
réponse ils sont restés exactement là où
ils ont été créés depuis 2 milliards
d'années alors c'est intéressant envoyés
à un site dont on s'est foutu on n'a pas
fait de débat national sur les déchets
n'est rien nature a fait les choses
n'importe comment le foot us à porte ou
là comme dans votre chambre
c'est dégueulasse et il s'est rien passé
de spécial c'est à dire que les déchets
sont restés très exactement à l'endroit
où ils ont été créés alors heureusement
les déchets concret nous ils vont pas
attendre 2 milliards d'années vous voyez
ici la vitesse de décroissance
radioactive des divers types de produits
que nous avons en sortie de réacteur est
en fait les déchets de fission comme ils
crachent énormément de radioactivité par
contrecoup lors 2010 n'est pas
extrêmement élevé vous voyez là vous
avez la radio occidentale l'activité de
l'uranium initial qui se manipule à
mains nues et voyez que les produits de
fission
ils vont pas du récent bilan au bout de
quelques siècles ils sont devenus
inoffensifs
ce qui va durer longtemps c'est
plutonium et le plutonium ici on recycle
et les actinides mineurs donc en fait le
deuxième
en jeu on va dire si on veut vraiment
être totalement débarrassée de tous les
emmerdements
mais bon c'est pas un gros emmerdements
ça m'est totalement débarrassé tous les
emmerdements c'est de faire des
réacteurs de génération 4 dans
lesquelles ça et ça ça brûle dans le
réacteur et donc on sort pas ce genre de
truc créateurs on ne sort que ça et ça
ça va durer quelques siècles ce qui est
pas ce qui n'est quand même pas un
problème majeur puisque le pont du gard
est beaucoup plus vieux par ailleurs
très rapidement tous les êtres vivants
sont exposées à la radioactivité
depuis qu'il ya de la vie sur terre
alors est ce que vous savez quel est
l'élément qui va le plus agressés vos
cellules et qui va briser l'adn de
chacune de vos cellules
j'insiste chacune de vos cellules des
centaines de fois par jour pas le soleil
non
un truc qui vous rendent par les narines
plusieurs fois par minute l'oxygène
l'oxygène est un occident vous rappeler
de ça et donc comme l'oxygène et un
occident
ça vous fait des radicaux libres qui se
baladent dans votre corps et qui vont
vous briser vos brindas dn2 chaque
cellule des centaines de fois par jour
et ça vous empêche pas de rester vivant
ça vous empêche pas de rester vivant
parce que comme l'a dit est apparue sur
terre dans un monde hostile soumis aux
bombardements cosmique aux rayonnements
ultraviolets du soleil etc
l'adn plusieurs dizaines de pourcents du
codage de l'adn
en fait c'est de ces du codage d'auto
réparation de l'adn donc l'adn des
centaines de fois par jour aussi s'auto
répare en deux temps en temps le truc
part en vrille et à ce moment vous avez
un tueur voilà mais même quand vous avez
une tumeur l'essentiel du temps c'est
une tumeur bénigne ou bien la cellule
meurt
un phénomène qui s'appelle la pop de
rezé la cellule meurt donc vous avez pas
dans le monde des vivants
il faut pas croire que les cellules sont
sans défense face aux agressions en fait
elles ont une panoplie de défendre la
radioactivité s'il ya des trucs qui peut
agresser l'adn mais c'est pas le seul
loin s'en faut donc tous les êtres
vivants sont soumis aux rayonnements
ionisants ils sont pas tous également
vulnérable aux rayonnements ionisants
comme vous pouvez voir ici j'ai pas le
temps d'entrer dans le détail les hommes
sont exposés à de la radioactivité
ils sont exposés à la radioactivité
naturelle à cause du bombardement
cosmique d'accord donc le rayonnement
cosmique
c'est la radioactivité naturelle à cause
de la radioactivité naturelle des roches
et c'est à cause du radon et c est à
cause la première source pour vous
vraisemblablement c'est les expositions
médicales
enfin pour les populations occidentales
c'est des expositions médicales dans
vous passer un scanner vous passer une
radio des poumons
est ce que je ne souhaite à aucune des
femmes dans cette salle
malheureusement les statistiques sont
contre vous si un jour vous fait traiter
un cancer du poumon
je peux vous assurer qu'on vous
irradiera copieusement mais en
l'occurrence pour vous sauver la vie en
tout cas c'est ce que pense le médecin
et il n'a pas tort donc mais c'est voilà
donc les l'irradiation la première
source des radiations de très loin celle
irradiation d'origine médicale
alors petite photo choc
est-ce que ça c'est tchernobyl c'est
bien la réponse est non ça c'est du
rachitisme conjuguée à une déficience en
fluor
alors je vous le montre pour choquer un
tout petit peu par l'image parce qu'il
n'ya rien de plus facile que de
détourner une image je peux vous assurer
que je prends n'importe quel journaliste
de france 3 et je lui dis ça c'est
tchernobyl il le passe directe au 20h
très très facile
rien de plus facile je les ai déjà vus
donc c'est pour ça que je vous dis voilà
donc ce n'est pas parce qu'il ya quelque
chose qui va de travers que c'est
nécessairement tchernobyl alors revenons
aux conséquences radiologiques du
nucléaire et par exemple aux retombées
de tchernobyl dans la population qui a
suivi les retombées de tchernobyl vous
avez de toute façon des gens qui meurent
vous avez de toute façon des gens qui
meurent de cancer il y avait des gens
qui meurent de cancer avant tchernobyl
donc pour savoir si tchernobyl ou sous
toute autre exposition aux rayonnements
ionisants provoque un surplus d'une
pathologie quelconque
il faut faire ce qu'on appelle des
études de cohorte c'est exactement comme
ça qu'on procède pour le tabac donc pour
savoir que le tabac c'est mauvais on
prend dix mille personnes qui fument et
10000 personnes qui sont décomposées
exactement de la même manière par sexe
par h par lieu de résidence par
habitudes alimentaires etc toutes égales
sauf qu'ils fument pas et puis on
regarde au cours du temps comment est-ce
que les deux comportent et si ceux qui
fument manifestement ont plus d'un
certain nombre de maires devant au cours
du temps des maladies cardiovasculaires
des cancers etc
que ceux qui fument pas on dit c'est la
faute au tabac et donc c'est comme ça
qu'on sait que le tabac provoque plus
d'accidents cardiovasculaires première
source de surmortalité due au tabac des
cancers du poumon mais pas que les
cancers de la vessie par exemple
augmentent avec le tabac donc vous avez
un certain nombre de trucs et on sait
que c'est ça avec ce qu'on appelle les
études de cohorte est bien pour le
nucléaire on procède exactement de la
même manière c'est à dire que vous
faites des cohortes et vous regarder des
gens qui ont été exposés avec des gens
qui n'ont pas été la difficulté avec les
gens avec le nucléaire c'est que le
tabac vous savez combien les gens fument
ils vont chez le tabagisme va chez le
buraliste et ils achètent des paquets de
cigarettes pour la radioactivité
poussan fasse que vous ayez un dosimètre
sur vous vous ne savez pas combien vous
êtes exposés à la radioactivité
donc la difficulté supplémentaire c'est
qu'il faut reconstituer cette exposition
à la radioactivité pour savoir quels
sont ses conséquences possibles dans la
population vous avez sélectionné
d'accord quand vous ne savez pas ça vous
ne pouvez pas tirer de conclusions alors
les conclusions qui ont été tirées des
études épidémiologiques
elles vous disent en gros deux choses
pour aller très vite aux résultats en
deçà leur pardon il ya aussi un truc
qu'il faut avoir mais je suis désolé
j'ai pas le temps de vous le définir
façon même si j'avais le temps vous
comprendriez rien parce que moi non plus
vous avez une unité qui est essentiel
non quand je dis moi non plus c'est pas
tout à fait vrai une unité qui est
essentielle en ce qui concerne l'impact
des rayonnements ionisants qui s'appelle
le cid verte et sont sous multiples qui
est 2006 date
donc vous avez peut-être déjà vu ce truc
là svm svm
alors soit dit en passant je ne pense
pas qu'il y ait un anti nucléaire vous
parlant de millisieverts qu'ils sachent
définir ce que c'est qu'un millisieverts
parce que la définition fait cinq pages
ou à peu près le millisievert tête une
unité dérivé du grès le grès est une
unité d'énergie transférés par le
rayonnement à la matière et qui vaut un
joule parking poids d'accord donc quand
vous avez reçu un gré c'est que le
rayonnement vous a transféré un joule
par kilo de poids une irradiation du
cancer du sein typique c'est 50 gré 50
jours par kilo poids sur trois mois
envoyez c'est pas une très grande unité
le milicien le si verte c'est un grès
fois un facteur multiplicatif qui dépend
du type de rayonnement donc le facteur
multiplicatif ses 20 pour les neutrons
mais j'ai pas quoi eu un pour le bêta
qui dépend du type d'organes considérer
qui dépend du fait que c'est une
exposition externe ou interne
enfin par exemple htc l'encyclopédie
votre truc mais c'est ça l'unité de
doses reçues qu'on utilise quand on
parle de la dangerosité des rayonnements
ionisants
alors avec cette unité là en dessous de
100 millisieverts par an on ne voit rien
si vous faites des études
épidémiologiques et que vous comparez
des gens qui reçoivent 80 et des gens
qui reçoivent 10 vous voyez pas de
différence c'est pour ça que thomas
pesquet prend le risque d'aller en
prendre 180 dans l'espace
en se disant normalement ça me fera rien
il a bien raison et c'est pour ça que
les hôtesses d'easyjet en prennent dix
dans l'année en se disant ça me fera
rien elles ont bien au dessus de 100 200
plus exactement
vous commencez à voir apparaître des
effets qui sont proportionnels à la dose
reçue encore donc si vous avez une
population qui est exposé à 400
millisieverts tu de tels types de
rayonnements
eh bien ça vous fera toutes choses
égales par ailleurs 50% dès que des
faits en plus que si vous avez reçu 300
en supposant qu à partir de 2 à 2,5 à
rien c'est ça le sait c'est ça l'idée ça
c'est les données d'observation
alors pour les conséquences de
tchernobyl première chose il faut
reconstituer l'exposition reçues et le
rayonnement reçue
et comme les gens n'avaient pas de
dosimètre sur eux ça veut dire vous
devez avoir un modèle qui vous
reconstitue la circulation atmosphérique
la demi vie des isotopes etc pour
imaginer qui a été exposé à quoi enfin
pour modéliser plus exactement pas
imaginer modéliser qui a été exposé à
quoi ça déjà c'est un truc avec des
incertitudes
ensuite vous n'avez vous avez un certain
nombre de pathologies qui existait avant
tchernobyl
ici par exemple vous avez l'incidence
des cancers à la thyroïde dans la
population française et tchernobyl et la
question est-ce que vous pensez que ça a
eu un effet discernable alors les gens
une partie des gens peuvent dire bah oui
ça monte ça monte pis là ça aurait dû
s'arrêter une autre partie des gens vous
disent non non il n'ya pas n'y a pas en
fait ce qu'ils font c'est la dérive et
la dérive et n'a pas changé et alors en
fait c'est le deuxième qui ont raison il
se trouve que l'on trouve plus de
cancers de la thyroïde à cavan pour
plein de raisons d'abord parce qu'on la
cherche
certes avant vous aviez des tas de gens
y mourrait on n'allait pas leur ouvrir
la thyroïde donc savais pas qu'il y
avait des modules ensuite la détection
paris la détection des nodules
s'améliore parce que l'imagerie devient
plus précise est donc aujourd'hui vous
détectez des trucs 1 mm alors qu'avant
voulait détecté à 1 cm mais c'est
toujours compté comme une détection
donc vous avez tout un tas de trucs
et puis vous avez vraiment une
augmentation de l'incidence qui est dû
facteurs environnementaux qu'on ne
connaît pas nécessairement mais pas ça
dernier point il faut savoir qu'à
tchernobyl il ya eu une augmentation de
l'incidence des cancers à la thyroïde
chez les enfants au moment de l'accident
mais pas chez les adultes parce que
quand vous êtes enfant votre thyroïde
est en train de se construire pour vous
absorbez de l'yonne en quantité plus
importante que quand vous êtes adulte
donc en fait la radioprotection à base
de diodes non à base pour saturer la
thyroïde diotte vous savez si jamais il
ya un accident alors vous donne des
pastilles diodes
en fait chez les adultes ça sert à rien
ça sert chez les enfants mais c'est pas
chez les adultes
je veux un cran plus loin
vous avez tous évidemment puisque vous
êtes venu à ce cours sauf un an pardon
je vous taquine sur le changement
climatique
vous avez donc tous entendu parler du
giec ipcc en anglais
le giec est une instance onusienne qui a
été créée sous la double tutelle de
l'union pendant 2 du programme des
nations unies pour l'environnement et de
l'organisation météorologique mondiale
et dont le mandat est de faire une
compilation de la littérature
scientifique disponible sur l'impact de
l'homme sur le climat
eh bien il se trouve qu'en 1955 il ya eu
une grande soeur ou un grand frère je ne
sais pas du giec qui a été créé avec le
même par an pour tous à gauche donc le
programme des nations unies pour
l'environnement et un autre par an pour
tous à droite
l'organisation mondiale de la santé et
le mandat du giec est très exactement le
même que celui du de l'unhcr pardon est
très exactement le même que celui du
giec mais dans un autre domaine
l'unhcr a pour mandat de faire une
compilation de la littérature
scientifique disponible sur l'impact des
rayonnements ionisants sur les êtres
humains dans un autre domaine parce
qu'on sait depuis un siècle depuis que
marie curie en est morte que la
radioactivité à haute dose c'est pas bon
et alors voilà le rapport de lune ce qui
est art sur fukushima a sorti en 2013
et c'est la phrase qui est en rouge que
je vous laisse lire parce que vous êtes
tous des anglicistes distinguer et vous
voyez la conclusion des études publiées
dans la littérature scientifique
en l'occurrence les revues médicales
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de conséquence
radiologique sur les hommes venant de
l'accident de fukushima n'a pas encore
fait la reconstitution des expositions
conjugué à ce qu'on sait sur les seuils
à partir desquels
dangereux d'être exposés font que on
sait les capable de dire qui aura pas de
conséquences radiologiques
il ya des conséquences à l'évacuation de
la population parce que ça crée du
stress des gens qui se mettent à fumer
et à boire etc et à celui-ci des sens
est par contre et même ça c'est pas
complètement clair soit dit en passant
mais mais on sait que ça a des
conséquences est absolument certain par
contre strictement radiologiques
l'autorité de sûreté canadienne après
fukushima j'ai accéléré parce qu'il est
quasiment 80 a décidé de restreindre le
périmètre d'évacuation autour des
centrales
justement sur la base de sa en dix ans
les morts que je vais créer en stressant
les gens en les évacuant c'est plus en
espérance mathématiques que ce que je
vais peut-être évité à cause des
retombées radiologique donc jeu
restreint le périmètre d'évacuation
ici vous avez un graff qui a été fait
qui a été publié aussi dans une revue
médicale et qui vous donne les morts par
térawattheures en ce qui concerne les
diverses sources de production
électrique est ce que vous voyez c'est
que le nucléaire accident compris est le
mieux placé parce que le charbon c'est
30 morts par térawattheures parce que
maladies pulmonaires des mineurs de
charbon parce que morts par accidents
dans les mines et parce que pollution
alors ben d'accord
donc si vous mettez tous un bout-à-bout
et bien ça vous fait 30 morts par
térawattheures etc et voyez que le
nucléaire est médicalement celle qui
présente le moins de risques après faut
vraiment que j'accélère donc si vous
n'êtes pas trop pressés à la fin du
cours je vous propose de venir poser la
question dans les deux minutes là encore
et puis après vous avez un sujet
évidemment qui est le sujet de la bombe
alors sujet de la bombe
il ya deux facteurs qui poussent dans le
sens de quand on a du nucléaire civil
c'est plus facile d'avoir la bombe
le premier c'est évidemment le corpus
commun de compétences sur un physicien
nucléaire qui sait ce que c'est qu'une
fiction et bien il n'est pas très loin
d'un physicien nucléaire qui sait ce que
c'est qu'une fiction dans une bombe cela
étant sur le plan technologique par
contre c'est quand même des technologies
qui sont assez distinctes heureusement
est par ailleurs comme je l'expliquais
tout à l'heure la filière
d'enrichissement du combustible est une
filière qui est potentiellement
proliférante puisqu'il suffit de
rajouter des étages et vous passez de
l'uranium qui sert dans une centrale à
l'uranium qui sert dans une bombe 1 235
alors après il se trouve que en fait les
données d'observation sur ce qui s'est
passé dans le monde vous montre qu' il
ya énormément de pays qui ont eu la
bombe qui n'ont jamais eu la moindre
centrale israël par exemple fait partie
de ces de ces pays là l'afrique du sud a
eu du potentiel
donc vous avez un certain nombre de pays
qui ont soit eu la bombe ayant renoncé
soit l'on le disparaît et c'est mai et
qui n'ont que j'avais eu la moindre
centrale
enfin en tout cas qui au moment où ils
ont mis la bombe n'avait pas la main de
centrales soit dit en passant c'est
aussi le cas des états unis et de la
russie au moment où ils ont eu accès à
l'armé atomique
donc ce que vous dit l'histoire c'est
qu'en fait la bombe vient avant tout de
l envie de la voir et pas avant tout du
fait d'avoir des centrales civiles
c'est pas le premier déterminant le
premier déterminant c'est vous ayez
envie d'avoir
inversement le fait que vous ayez des
centrales civiles
si vous décidez de des commissions des
bombes il faut que vous sachiez quoi
faire de l'uranium qui a dans les bombes
et du plutonium qui a dans les bombes et
un truc qui est très bien pour être sûr
que vous ayez plus la bombe ces deux le
cramé dans une centrale du caire
enfin bien sûr que vous l'avez plus si
vous dites je le mets dans un coin et
puis je vous garantie gie toucherait pas
va vous pouvez éventuellement vous dire
que c'est fait une promesse d'ivrogne
alors que si vous le mettez pas dans un
coin mais dans une centrale et vous le
brûler là vous êtes sûr on y touche lui
a plu voilà donc c
c'est plus compliqué qu'il n'y paraît
cette histoire entre entre civils et
militaires
alors je vais accélérer parce que ça je
vous en ai déjà parlé la génération 4 je
vous en ai parlé rapidement aussi donc
j'accélère alors la question pour finir
ce truc là c'est si on veut que le
nucléaire y tiennent là dans le haut du
graphique c'est à dire qu'il soit un
contributeur très significatif à la
décarbonation d'une société qui ne
renoncerait pas à son confort d'accord
c'est ça la question à laquelle en
arrive
eh bien il faut qu'il soit capable de
faire du puy 5 à 10% par an et là
évidemment on tombe sur un certain
nombre de questions par exemple le
savent on s'en fout parce que je les ai
déjà parlé c'est plutôt ça
la question c'est est-ce qu'on a la
possibilité de faire en quelques
dizaines d'années un parc de quelques
aller de quelques milliers de réacteurs
sachant qu'on en a aujourd'hui 450 dans
le monde
voilà ça la question donc est ce qu on a
l'argent parce que comme je le disais
tout à l'heure il faut de l'argent alors
l'argent il y en a il y en a plein
la question c est ce qu on a l'argent
qu'ils acceptent d'aller s'investir là
dedans c'est plutôt ça la question
donc est ce qu on a soit des états qui
dit c'est comme ça et on discute pas ce
qui est le cas de la chine soit un monde
privé qui dit j'en est vachement envie
parce que tout bien pesé c'est beaucoup
moins risqué plus reste est à ce moment
qu il le fait pour le moment vous l'avez
pas c'est plutôt l'inversé l'europe par
exemple considère que le nucléaire c'est
pas vers donc en ce moment il ya une
réglementation qui est en train de se
mettre en place à la commission
européenne sur ce qu'on appelle les
investissements verts dans la finance et
le nucléaire est explicitement exclue
comme étant un truc pas vers ce qui est
de mon point de vue est une erreur mais
je ne suis qu'un d'électeurs parmi 400
millions d'européens autre question est
y aura les compétences parce que dans
beaucoup de sujets si on veut changer de
système de bout en bout
il faut qu'ils les gens qui sont
capables de faire ensuite est-ce qu'on
saura si prendre suffisamment à l avance
parce que le centrale nucléaire ça se
construit quand même un peu moins vite
qu'une fuite en paille
donc une fois qu'on a décidé de le faire
c'est pas la semaine d'après gaussens
pas le sort de terre voilà est-ce qu'on
sait où les maîtres alors ça en
l'occurrence oui parce qu'on peut les
mettre à la place des centrales à
charbon
voilà donc le la fin quantitative de cet
exposé c'est que pendant et je vais
finir avec un élément que je vous ai pas
projeter leur âme et qui vient du
dernier rapport 1.5 du giec dans le
rapport 1.5 du giec tous les scénarios
d'émissions qui permettent de rester
sous la barre des 1 degré et demi sont
des scénarios qui voit un nucléaire x 2
à 6 d'ici à 2100 je crois de mémoire
donc c'est tous des scénarios dans
lesquels le nucléaire se développe
évidemment il n'y a pas que ça qui se
développe il ya aussi les énergies
renouvelables et les économies d'énergie
mais voilà donc pour pour finir cet
exposé quand on regarde pour vous donner
une conclusion un peu personnel
quand on regarde les avantages et les
inconvénients
donc les avantages du nucléaire et ses
risques un monde qui renonce au
nucléaire est paradoxalement un monde
qui acceptent de courir plus de risques
qu'un monde qui souhaite en faire plus
encore en termes d'arbitrages des
risques parce que si vous en faites - ou
bien vous augmentez l'envi de recourir à
des modes fossiles qui sont
potentiellement porteur de risques on a
vu au moment du cours sur le changement
climatique qui sont à des échelles qui
n'ont strictement rien à voir
ou bien vous prenez le pari qu'on va y
arriver juste avec des renouvelables
moderne dont on parlera aux prochains
cours et vous verrez que c'est un pari
dont je ne suis pas complètement sûr
qu'il peut réussir comme ça
compte tenu des éléments on va voir ou
bien vous prenez de paris pardon que la
société va être capable de résister à
une contraction rapide de son
approvisionnement énergétique puisque
vous ne faites ni fossiles ni nucléaire
avec les renouvelables sont pas
suffisantes
tout en restant stables compte tenu de
ce qu'on a vu au premier cours sur le
lien entre l'activité productive et
l'énergie quand donc vous avez un
arbitrage entre ces trois risques il n'y
a pas de repas gratuits dans cette
histoire il ya un arbitrage entre ces
trois risques et ma conclusion
personnelle que je serai à partager
c'est que dans cet arbitrage entre ces
trois risques c'est très paradoxal de
dire ça en france mais plus on fait de
nucléaire et moins encore de risque
voilà en gros ça n'exclut pas du tout le
fait qu'il faut faire énormément
d'économie d'énergie et qu'il y aura
plein de renouvelables intéressante dans
un certain nombre de cas de figure mais
globalement c'est ça ma conclusion voilà
je suivrai encore une fois vraiment
désolé d'avoir zappé le leur correcte de
début on a réussi à faire tenir
l'essentiel dans le temps qui restait
voilà oui
c'est à dire
à alors aujourd'hui la politique
française est une politique et j'espère
que je ne vais choquer obtient
d'anciennes élèves de ginette dans cette
salle mais c'est une politique
mensuellement jésuites c'est à dire que
c'est une politique qui consiste à dire
j'en fais tout et n'ayant d'en faire
tout en trouvant quand même c'est pas
mal d'en faire et que je veux dire que
je vais en faire un peu plus d'un côté
tout en disant je vais en faire un peu
moins de l'autre non mais c'est
exactement ça en france donc c'est le
genre de truc que vous sort votre grain
quand vous l'avez pris la main dans le
pot de confiture et qu'ils essayent de
vous expliquer que non non il n'y avait
pas du tout c'est exactement ça la
position du pouvoir français en ce
moment alors du côté plus on a demandé à
edf de commencer à regarder où elle
allait construire de nouvelles centrales
donc on a mis en route une simple la
construction d'une centrale à
flamanville qu'on a mise en route avant
les 2 op r qu'on a commencé à construire
à taishan en chine qu'on terminera après
si la série golo parce que plus la
centrale a été commencé tôt plus elle
sera terminée tard donc
alors c'est pas tout à fait vrai pas
tout à fait faux parce que pas tout à
fait vrai parce que olkiluoto en
finlande sera probablement lancée avant
flamanville quand même mais bon peu
importe les règles ne sont pas tout à
fait les mêmes
je vais vous donner un exemple alors il
est caricatural mais c'est que pour vous
comprenez bien en france vous avez un
couvercle de cuve que vous laissez
tomber par terre l'asn vous dit vous
leur faites en chine vous laissez tomber
le congrès de cus par peut porter je
tiens ça de dirigeants de framatome les
chinois le passé aux rayons x test à
l'hélium vache un autre qui dit ça va
bien je m'installe donc c'est voilà donc
c'est pas du tout maintenant mais les
deux se défendre
chinois ont un très bon passeur qui
court beaucoup plus de risques donc
donc là on a on a dit à et df fait des
nouvelles centrales
mais dans le même temps on lui dit fait
descendre
enfin on va descendre la part du
nucléaire à 50% on dit également cette
descente à 50% est destiné à avoir moins
de réacteurs sauf que je sais pas si
j'aurai le temps que vous montrez la
prochaine fois mais il ya une page sur
mon site perso qui dissertent là dessus
qu'ils s'appellent 50 % ou 50 % pour
ceux qui ont envie d'aller voir donc
j'explique que l'observation du quart
allemand et le cas espagnol fait que moi
si j'ai mon propre argent à parier je
suis prêt à le faire
50% de nucléaire ça ne veut pas dire
qu'on ferme un réacteur sur trois ça
veut dire qu'on va baisser de 30% le
facteur de charge de l'ensemble du parc
nucléaire
parce que une nuit d'hiver sans vent
vous accepterez pas que les trains
n'avance pas que le laminoir fonctionne
pas que l'enfant à 19 heures un soir
d'hiver que l'ascenseur n'arrive pas que
vous soyez dans noir et que votre
cuisinière marche pas il acceptera y
passa et donc on va garder les centrales
nucléaires en sécurité et on les fait
fonctionner quand ya pas de vent et pas
de soleil on sait exactement ce qu'ont
fait les allemands
les allemands ont la même puissance
électrique pilotable aujourd'hui qu'il
avait il ya 17 ans quand même 100
gigawatts
sauf que le facteur de charge a baissé
d'1 5% ou plus peine 30% alors qu'est ce
qui se passe si vous faites baisser de
facteurs de charge d'un système à coûts
fixes
vous faites baisser ses recettes alors
que les coûts sont les mêmes
donc en fait vous allez augmenter le
risque nucléaire donc le programme
français et un truc qui est destiné à
augmenter le risque nucléaire
c'est ça ma conclusion tout en vous
disant que c'est l'inversé on dit en
france c'est caca berck mais quand même
si on pouvait avoir des succès à
l'exportation ça serait quand même
vachement bien donc chez nous on va
fermer fessenheim est quand même si on
pouvait en furie au coréen appelant
coréen à abou dhabi ça se passe bien
et puis quand même le fait que les
finlandais y prennent le deuxième
réacteur chéreau satom alors que nous on
est vachement bien alors fournir quand
même c'est des gens pas sympa bon
d'accord ils tueront de foot quoi
maintenant
le latitude française aujourd'hui sur le
nucléaire et le truc le plus ambivalent
qui soit et le plus comment nous te
place un jour à gauche un jour à droite
un jour à gauche un joueur à droite etc
et c'est le reflet notamment d'une
opinion qui elle-même est un peu
hésitante site comprend pas bien etc
voilà les anglais ont une attitude
beaucoup plus cash sur le nucléaire et
le disent nous on n'en veut
si les français vous n'êtes pas capables
d'en faire on envoie aux chinois les
russes en sont pleins et du reste le
carnet de commandes de rosatom il ya 30
réacteurs dedans et on sait même pas
comment ils vont faire pour les
construire tellement rien non puis
continuer à engranger encore plein les
chinois ils doivent voir 20 réacteurs en
construction
j'avais fait une intervention pour liane
sdn
il ya quelques années dans laquelle
j'avais dit en conclusion je suis
absolument certain qui aura duré du
nucléaire dans 30 ans si d'ici là on n'a
pas une météorite qui nous est tombé
dessus ou la guerre thermonucléaire ou
un virus qui ne va éradiquer
je suis certain la seule question est de
savoir s'il sera chinois en chine
chinois en france aux français en france
mais sinon je suis sûr qu'il en aura 6
il ya toujours quoi que ce soit qui
ressemble à une humanité à peu près
industriel absolument certain du coup on
prend du retard parce que quand vous
avez un actionnaire qui arrête pas de
dire à sa filiale ce que tu fais c'est
pas terrible mais fellow quand même mais
quand même c'est pas terrible et puis je
veux dire publiquement que c'est pas
terrible mais quand même fait le camp
même temps le vent commence à se
retourner un tout petit peu dans
l'opinion
je rencontre de plus en plus de gens qui
étaient classiquement prédestiné à être
anti nucléaire si vous me pardonnez
cette façon caricaturale d'étiqueter les
gens plutôt du bobo de gauche bien
pensants qui se met à me dire mais c'est
complètement stupide de fermer des
réacteurs nucléaires ont donc des gens
inattendu j'ai envie de dire qui voit là
c'est intéressant de constater que on
commence à en voir quelques uns
dépanner et pas nécessairement des mois
oui eh bien je voulais dit je ne sais
pas il ya la question est pourquoi
est-ce que le nucléaire fait partie de
ces quelques sujets n'y en a pas tant
que ça
mais de ces quelques sujets où la
compréhension de la population sur les
dangers et raisonnablement orthogonale à
la réalité des dangers
vous avez un certain nombre de dangers
environnementaux sur lesquels les gens
peuvent avoir une idée un peu exagéré ou
au contraire pas assez présente quelque
part sous-estimer les 8 mai quand même
comprendre que entre guillemets ça pue
par exemple sur la question des
changements climatiques
les gens n'ont pas nécessairement en
tête la réalité des risques mais
comprend bien que c'est un truc
emmerdant sur les phytosanitaires les
gens ont pas en tête la réalité des
risques mais ils comprennent bien qu'un
truc qui est bazarder dans la nature
pour tuer des êtres vivants en
l'occurrence des insectes ou des herbes
il ya un moment où ça doit pas être
terrible pour nous d'accord donc il faut
aller regarder d'un peu près c'est une
question de dose de machin truc etc mais
que quand même on peut se poser la
question
toujours sur la pêche par exemple il ya
des gens qui peuvent se dire oui
effectivement on voit les stocks de
poissons baissé il va bien se passer
quelque chose
il ya quelques sujets environnementaux
pas tant mais quelques-uns lee nucléaire
en faisant partie où il ya en france
j'insiste sur le fait que ces français
parce que c'est pas vrai dans tous les
pays du monde un écart assez
significatif entre les faits documentés
par la littérature scientifique papa la
technologie de la littérature
scientifique au sens de j'observe le
monde et l'opinion qu'on peut en avoir
quelques hypothèses c'est des hypothèses
donc faut vraiment les prendre comme tel
de différence entre les deux la première
c'est que dans la presse l'anti nuclear
isme si vous l'observez bien est
essentiellement le fait des médias de
service public qui se considèrent comme
tels jan aps le monde se considère comme
un média de service public
quand vous êtes dans un médiateur alors
l'hypothèse que je fais j'aime bien
c'est une hypothèse c'est que quand vous
êtes dans un média vous voulez montrer
vous êtes indépendant
j'organiserai qu'il est indépendant qui
est à la botte de personnes et si c'est
l'état qui vous paye la meilleure
manière de montrer que vous n'êtes pas à
la botte de l'état c'est à dire du mal
de ce que fait l'état
donc si vous êtes journaliste de service
public et ça par contre c'est aussi un
truc que vous allez pouvoir marquer vous
allez dire préférentiellement du mal de
la police de la façon dont on organise
le système d'enseignement de la façon
dont fonctionne l'hôpital de la sncf etc
et à ce moment je pense que le nucléaire
passe tout simplement dans ce grand
ensemble comme c'est un truc que fait
l'état craque ça passe dans tous les
trucs que l'état fait de travers et vous
pouvez vous pouvez remarquer que quand
vous avez une émission jeu pourquoi
complémente enquête investigations
spéciales etc
sur france 2 ou sur france 3 ça n'est
que de l'instruction à charge donc on va
pas vous amener un médecin vous avez vu
montrer que c'était les médecins qui
détenait les clefs de lecture sur est-ce
que c'est dangereux ou pas pour la santé
j'en ferai jamais un c'est les
ingénieurs que ça vous dire comment
fonctionne un réacteur vous en verrez
jamais un c'est les physiciens qui ça
vous expliquer ce que c'est que le
nucléaire vous en verrez jamais un vous
verrez les militants antinucléaires
toujours les mêmes c'est un parti pris
de la presse et je vous dis que j'ai une
explication putative mais ça ne salent
reste une hypothèse
après il ya également un deuxième truc
qui à mon avis pèse en france c'est le
tandem franco allemand
la france considère depuis très
longtemps que le socle fondateur de
l'europe c'est le couple franco allemand
alors il ya des tas de bonnes raisons de
penser que c'est vrai mais il se trouve
que les allemands eux le nucléaire est
un sujet qui est historiquement beaucoup
plus affectif que en france ils ont eu
deux fusées pershing sur leur sol est un
traumatisme
ça rappelle la seconde guerre mondiale
enfin bon c'est plein de trucs qui sont
assimilés affection associée a dépensé
beaucoup plus affectif que pour nous
français est donc dans le couple franco
allemand
il ya eu en gros ces allemands qui font
tous bien ils ont une économie qui tient
la route
une barrière industrie etc par ailleurs
il aime pas le nucléaire
les jeux c'est pareil c'est une
hypothèse mais je me dis c'est un
peut-être joué un rôle
le fait que la france s'est
progressivement écartés d'une industrie
nucléaire bon au début elle a été
extrêmement fier je veux dire par les
années 70-80 la population accuse alors
aujourd'hui même la population vous avez
50 % de prod tiède 30% d'anti tiède et
15 % de gens qui vous disent qu'ils
savent pas si vous regardez dans le dans
la manière dont les gens disent il
importe donc cessé un essai j'ai pas
fini mon étude de cas sociologique pour
savoir pourquoi la situation se présente
comme ça dans notre pays c'est ça reste
un truc ça reste pas à mystères non
résolus mais ça reste une question
partiellement non résolus oui après il
ya une question fond
au siège qui vous fait en fermant
commune ps verts
ça va aller bah du coup je pensais que
j'avais pas le temps alors la fusion est
ce que ça marche
alors si ça marche oui le problème c'est
que comme réacteurs industriel ça
marchera pas avant vous soyez morts
alors je vous la fait courte mais bonne
aujourd'hui on est en train de
construire terre iter alors la fusion
c'est quoi ces vous mettez la matière
sous forme de plasma vous savez tous que
c'est qu'un plasma donc un plasma ces
quelques millions de degrés est pour
porter la matière à quelques millions de
degrés pour la chauffer donc vous avez
un investissement initial en énergie
pour porter la matière à quelques
millions de degrés
iter par ailleurs une fois que la
matière et à quelques millions de degrés
c'est compliqué de mettre ça dans une
boîte en plastique alors ça ne tiendrait
pas bien donc il faut donc la seule
manière que vous avez de confiner ça
c'est dans un champ magnétique et ça
tombe bien c'est une matière ionisée
d'un champ magnétique
donc en fait le principe de la fusion si
vous faites un champ magnétique pour
confiner la matière en fusion sous forme
de tore et déclencher le plasma sous
forme de tore est déclenchée dans ce
plasma une réaction de fusion le iter
est un est quelque chose qui est destiné
à vérifier est un engin qui est destiné
à valider expérimentalement la
possibilité de retirer un peu plus
d'énergie de fusion que l'énergie que
vous avez utilisé pour mettre le
placement en chauffe donc avec iter on
sera content si on fait de la fusion sur
quelques minutes actuellement dans les
tokamaks vous êtes plutôt à quelques
secondes avant tout c'est un gros
tokamak donc faut encore dix ans pour
qu'on sourit terre premier plasma 2025
est annoncée vous faites fonctionner 10
en 2035
après vous vous grattez la tête pendant
cinq ans pour savoir ce que vous allez
faire derrière 2040
puis vous commencez à construire le truc
qui est derrière éventuellement un
prototype de réacteur de fusion c'est à
dire un truc où la fusion du repas deux
minutes mais 5000 heures parce que dans
les réacteurs nucléaires actuelles la
réaction du rpt 5000 heures alors voir
elle dure trois ans dans vingt-quatre
mille heures sans s'arrêter
vous pouvez pas faire un réacteur
industriels pour servir la population en
électricité avec un stock qui font des
marais côtiers dix minutes moi je vois
bien donc il faut faire le truc d'après
don jeudi 2025 2035 2040
on décide de construire un démonstrateur
de réacteurs industrielle de fusion en
2000 55 60
il est prêt en 2070 il a fonctionné 10
ans et en 2075 vous commencez à
construire une tête de série qui sera
donc terminée d'être construite en 2090
ou 2095 et à vous serez mort depuis
longtemps donc donc la fusion avec les
échéances que je vous ai montré à la
fois sur le changement climatique et sur
la question d'approvisionnement en
combustibles fossiles dans les zones qui
commence à être un peu contrainte
notamment l'europe
vous oubliez ça fait pas partie des
moyens du bord et toujours pour rester
dans le politiquement incorrect je fais
partie des gens extrêmement pro
nucléaires qui n'auraient jamais mis un
centime dans iter car s'il en avait
dépendu que moi on n'aurait jamais fait
on aura mis cet argent dans un programme
de quatrième génération accéléré dans la
fission jamais débouché par une amie
questions vont
oui
alors comme disent les américains
batibouw questionner quand ils veulent
être poli et que leurs intérieures
intacte très bonne question
manière de se mettre les journalistes
dans la poche en finale alors il faut
savoir qu'une centrale nucléaire
c'est un assemblage de legos
donc ce n'est pas un objet monobloc qui
a une durée de vie en tant qu'objet
monobloc c'est un assemblage de legos
dans laquelle chaque briques de lego a
sa propre durée de vie est en fait le
seul briques de lego que vous ne pouvez
pas changer dans une centrale nucléaire
une fois que vous l'avez construite
c'est la cuve du réacteur
tout le reste vous pouvez le changer et
donc un grand paradoxe par exemple c'est
que fessenheim est entre guillemets une
des centrales les plus neuves du parc
français parce que comme elle a été
construite il ya longtemps il ya
longtemps qu'on a changé tout ce qu'on
pouvait changer à l'intérieur on a
changé les alternateurs les générateurs
de vapeur les machins les groupes
électrogènes de secours alors vous
n'avez pas tout changer donc vous
changer au cours à l'est et en fait vous
avez donc en fait le constructeur vous
dis moi je fais des plans pour que ça
dure au moins tant de temps mais c'est
pas quelque chose qui a une du
commandeur la seule pièce pour laquelle
ce truc là
tiens ils vont éventuellement quelque
chose heureusement c'est la cuve du
réacteur
du coup comme tout le reste vous pouvez
changer la manière dont ça se passe
c'est que vous avez l'autorité de sûreté
qui vient tous les dix ans regardez le
réacteur et vous dire il est bon pour le
service tel qu'il se présente pour les
10 ans qui viennent
quoi que vous fassiez dessus je décide
de l'arrêter
serge ce truc ne tient plus la route et
dont en particulier la cub j'estime que
ces fragilités font qu' elle ne peut pas
garantir un fonctionnement sûr pour les
années qui viennent
ou bien un truc intermédiaires qui en
france est plus souvent le cas je vous
remercie une dix ans à condition que
vous fassiez çà çà çà çà çà et 100
d'accord vous me changer d'aile machin
vous rajoutez tel truc et c'est post
fukushima par exemple l'asn a demandé à
edf de mettre toutes ses centrales
nucléaires en conformité avec des normes
de sûreté plus élevé par exemple mettre
sous le bâtiment réacteur
un radier pour et un radier pour
récupérer le corium si jamais le coeur
font enfin voilà un certain nombre de
trucs
et donc dans le grand carénage que bdf a
démarré vous avez une partie des
investissements qui sont une
augmentation des normes de sûreté que
l'asn a demandé aux réacteurs français
les réacteurs français on avait dit au
début on se la donne pour 40 ans
aujourd'hui et des f10 on va les
prolonger à 50 ou 60
si on peut il aussi on peut c'est si
l'asn nous donne l'autorisation de le
faire dit autrement et df considère que
si des scènes de l'autorisation
ça ne fait pas courir de risque de les
exploiter à 50 ou 60 ans aux états unis
je vous ai dit qu'il y avait une
centaine de réacteurs en fonctionnement
la quasi totalité des 100 sinon la
totalité des 100 réacteurs en
fonctionnement ont été autorisés pour 60
ans la quasi totalité cela est dans la
philosophie de l'autorité de sûreté
américaine est différente parce que eux
ils considèrent qu'à tout instant le
réacteur doit être conforme à ses
spécifications de départ alors qu'en
france comme je disais tout à l'heure à
tout instant vous devez être conformes
aux spécifications du moment qui se
durcissent avec le temps mais donc aux
etats-unis ont dit si à tout instant
c'est conforme à ce que ça devait faire
au moment où vous avez construit le
réacteur bat bien et donc ils ont tous
demandé leur extension à 60 ans et il y
aura un certain nombre qui commence à
réfléchir à l'extension à 80 et 2 fait
tant que vous n'avez pas de défaut sur
la cuve
ça ne pose pas le problème de principe
d'accord et pour revenir au pont du gard
danse parlais tout à l'heure
tant que pont du gard les pierres ne se
fissure pas il peut continuer à servir
de pompe et ça fait 2000 ans qui sert de
pont et si ça se trouve il peut encore
servir de pont de bilan alors qu'il ya
longtemps que le pont construit par un
constructeur que je ne nommerai pas
relié à un endroit que je ne nommerai
pas un autre endroit que je ne devrais
pas se casser la gueule comme le pont
jane non mais voilà donc c'est c1
la processus
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que en
fait cette notion de durée de vie il n'a
pas tellement d'intérêt parce qu'encore
une fois ces mots ne sais pas me bloque
et que c'est un processus d'évaluation
permanente de l'état de ce que vous avez
en face de vous qui est la bonne réponse
oui
ils en sont ils en sont au même stade
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui personne
n'est capable de vous faire un plasma
qui reste en fusion pendant cinq mineurs
oui mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
iter par ailleurs il était décidé que ça
coûte 30 milliards d'euros je pense que
là on doit être rendu à 50 ou 60 ou 90
après le facteur pis donc je suis pas
complètement sûr que admettons qu'on
fasse un réacteur de fusion d'ici à ce
que vous mourriez ok on change
strictement rien à ce que je voulais
raconter parce que c'est pas la même
chose parce que c'est quand même
beaucoup plus simple de faire fissionner
en matériaux en laissant le matériau à
quelques centaines de degrés que de
porter un plasma quelques millions de
degrés peut-être juste beaucoup plus
simple pardon d'eux a alors davantage
c'est que tout ce que nous pouvons nous
le ferons il ya un philosophe qui a dit
ça tout ce que nous pouvons nous le
ferons donc quand vous êtes parti dans
une filière
à un moment on va créer de la recherche
il ya des physiciens qui ont découvert
les interactions fortes
donc ils ont commencé à regarder ce qui
se passait à l'intérieur du noyau
ils ont compris que sur le papier on
pouvait fusionner des protons et que
c'est enfin ou dur et qu'on pourrait
fusionner les noyaux et que ça faisait
des loyers aux plus lourds ils ont
constaté que c'était ça qui se passait
dans le soleil et ils sont ni tiens ça
serait rigolo essayer de faire pareil et
donc tout ce que nous pouvons nous
ferons
pour elle ce qu'on fait des taxis volant
dans paris pour est-ce que la ratp rêve
de faire des taxis volant dans paris
parce que tout ce que nous pouvons y
serons c'est juste d'abord on fait pas
ce canton ça rigolo de faire des trucs
nouveaux et ensuite on se pose la
question de savoir si c'était une bonne
idée pour tous moi je veux dire
aujourd'hui en l'occurrence non mais
c'est exactement ça c'est un regard
regarder l'histoire des techniques
c'est ça du début à la fin tout ce que
nous pouvons au fond
alors oui alors pourquoi est-ce qu'on
fait les réacteurs qu'on fait
aujourd'hui une bonne question
il se trouve que par exemple au début
des années 50
les militaires américains avaient
envisagé ne veut parler pas ça vous
amuse et cette anecdote les militaires
américains avaient envisagé de faire un
avion de combat avec un réacteur à sels
fondus pas du tout la même technologie
parce que c'est des réacteurs qui sont
extrêmement réactif et donc capa vous
êtes capable de piloter une puissance de
deux manières comme comme une [ __ ]
d'accélérateur
alors en fait la raison pour laquelle on
est parti sur la technologie qu'on
utilise aujourd'hui d'après ce que j'ai
compris bajoues sait il faudrait que je
les réussis mais d'après ce que j'ai
compris c'est parce que ses dérivés des
premiers réacteurs qui ont été mis au
point pour des raisons militaires qui
étaient des réacteurs de propulsion de
bâtiments de guerre marine en fait les
réacteurs qu'on fait aujourd'hui à coeur
solide à l'uranium sont d'abord la
filière uranium on est partis dessus
parce que c'est ce qui permet de faire
des armes l'uranium 235 et plutonium
alors que la filière thorium non donc ça
a été un des critères de choix entre
l'uranium et thorium et ensuite les
réacteurs refroidis à aux hackers solide
c'est une technologie avec laquelle vous
pouvez faire des réacteurs assez compact
que vous pouvez embarquer sur des porte
avions des sous marins et donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle on a commencé par
développer ses réacteurs là qu'on savait
faire qu'une fois qu'on savait faire
cela confère ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure tous que nous savons tous que
nous pouvons nous ferons dont on les a
faits et ensuite on s'est dit tiens on
peut en faire de l'électricité aussi et
donc c'est cette technologie là
qu'on a dérivé pour faire de
l'électricité à ce moment là on s'est
pas dit on va reprendre la copie à 0 et
les réacteurs pour faire de
l'électricité on va éventuellement
utiliser une technologie totalement
différente
on avait ça dans les cartons et donc
c'est ça qu'on a utilisées oui parce que
une fois que vous avez des industriels
qui sont installés sur le marché avec
une technologie dominante on reste à ça
tant qu'ils sont pas menacés tant qu'on
a pas inventé la photo numérique c'est
qu'aulas qui dominent le marché
donc là tant que vous avez des gens qui
ont mis au point des technologies qui
avait déjà en première usagers donc ils
avaient déjà les brevets il avait déjà
les ingénieurs qui savait faire il avait
déjà etc
s'il suffit de faire la même chose en
plus gros ben vous avez un avantage
concurrentiel terrible par rapport aux
gens qui repart de zéro dans leur labo
c'est évident pour que c'est la filière
industrielle qui va aller de l'avant
alors aujourd'hui il ya un certain
nombre de gens encore une fois qui se
gratte la tête sait on est un peu en
train de rebattre les cartes
mais c'est il n'empêche que la
technologie dominante
et pour encore longtemps sur le marché
c'est la technologie car solide
l'uranium iranien enrichi
refroidissement à l'eau
[Musique]
en faute de questions c'est-à-dire de
combattants on lève la séance
bon et bien comme dans avec bones
assemblée de copropriété le
procès-verbal vidéo est terminée et donc
la semaine prochaine cette fois c'est
eux